work with that louis ck never never no
20 years ago
i met louie 20 years ago in seattle
did you guys speak spanish because you
know he was raised in mexico louis ck
yeah this is first first language
spanish i didn't know that yeah
yeah yeah i've been watching his show
and uh
really impressed about his his writing
his writing has always been money yeah
his writing has always been mine hit it
we'll talk about this in the show yeah
this show is presented by on it
the days are back the church of what's
happening now was proud to introduce you
to hellotushy.com hellotushy.com makes
portable devices that spray your butt
clean with water go to hellotushy.com
church right now to get 10 off it was
the thing i miss most when i'm away from
home it's the first thing i do when i
get home hellotushy.com
church show is also brought to you by
meundies
go to meundies.com joey to get 20 off of
your first order with free shipping in
the us and canada off of all their
comfortable underwear t-shirts socks and
more
meundies.com
joey
oh [ __ ]
and you thought you were doing it right
without your uncle joey [ __ ] no
happy thanksgiving to you [ __ ]
lee syed my little goomba
and my main man rudy sarzo in studio yo
november the 22nd
kick that mu lee ah
take a
time get get down
[Music]
all alone
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what's up what was that that's a
cool bass red that's a old
like a 10 12 15 years ago what's the
name of the band again cake cake cake
and they have a couple great albums
somebody left and there was a problem
but i went to see him with felipe a
couple years ago oh yeah at uh one of
these clubs on sunset the big one at the
theater like that and they were great
they were great so what's up papa oh
just hanging happy thanksgiving thank
you too
yeah hey you were telling the story here
when you played the palladium that night
that you went from sleeping on the floor
to being at the plaza and [ __ ] yeah
because you know uh you know sharon was
uh not only the manager for the band but
she was tour managing
and she had to stay and you know i mean
everybody stayed together it wasn't like
ozzie and sharon stayed in some posh
hotel and then the band stayed at the
motel six no everybody went
wherever they went we went we're
traveling the bus together everything as
a matter of fact i was staying with them
uh in uh sharon's family's home in
benedict canyon
so
i i while i was in the band i was with
them like 24 7 for like you know from
1981 to the end of 82.
you know so
getting to the story is you know we we
were going to play the palladium
the following day we just drove in
from i think we're in binghamton or
somewhere like that uh about a couple
hours away and we drove in tour bus we
got to the venue
i mean we got to to the plaza and uh
i got off the bus and you know they i
check in and the guy throws me a key i
went into my room and there was somebody
asleep so i went back down to
to the uh
to the guy and say hey listen um i need
another key uh so he says okay he gives
me the key i go up to the room and the
room is a mess uh the um you know
the beds weren't made or anything so
went back down again i said look i have
to get up early we're doing a lot of
press we got the gig
uh we i just finished doing a gig
i'm knackered i'm tired so he said okay
i'm gonna give you this room but you
better check out
you know tomorrow i say okay i don't
care so i just white follow i went to
the room and i realized i'm staying at
one of the suites they have like the
special suites on each corner
so it's like you know you have like a
quarter of the whole building you know
to you to yourself and it was just this
1981 i don't know if things have changed
now but that's the way it was back then
and it was just i i i couldn't go to
sleep because here i am and i i'm
thinking wow maybe just one of these
suites where the beetles stay when they
came and played that sullivan so i was
like having all these
all these weird you know thoughts and
and i'm like rolling on the floor naked
and [ __ ] you know and and
so i went to the bathroom and i sat in
the toilet and realized that the toilet
that my ass was facing
it was a big window so my ass was facing
the park
you know central park who could see in
the [ __ ] 18 yeah but yeah it was like
you know four o'clock in the morning
yeah by the time that i you know that
i'm doing all this and it's like yeah i
figured you know nobody's doing but it
just it was it was nuts because just a
few weeks before that i was sleeping on
the floor in kevin durant's apartment
you know so this was like man this is
totally insane and kevin was living here
at the time and and yeah it was a ride
of cold water and riverside
oh my god yeah
so how long have you been walking these
valley [ __ ] streets oh man the valley
the valley you know now i i love the
valley i i wouldn't want to live
anywhere else but to be in the valley
back in the 70s was kind of like
excommunicated from from rock and roll
because when i first got to la in 76
76
77 i was living right off the strip
right of holloway and we're halloween
sunset meet right there to say this is
this little street right there palm
and uh
yeah i was living there so i would walk
everywhere you know across the street
was tower records and you have the old
world and i was working at a place
called make naturals
which was a fast food health food place
and uh we're making veggie burgers and
i'm i i can make a kick-ass veggie
burger you know i still remember how to
make those and uh
and a couple of blocks you know what one
block down was um
filthy mcnasty's which now is the viper
room yeah and then another block is
where where you you know that's uh
uh where you where where the uh the
whiskey is and then beyond that of
course you got gazaris and you got the
roxy and the rainbow and all that so you
know i was living in the heart of it
now what were you doing in the daytime
working and then that you got all those
clothes yeah yeah as a matter of fact
i would put my hair in a ponytail or
stick it inside my shirt
and i would work at mac naturals then
they would give me the key and say okay
you lock it up and you know mop up the
floor and whatever so the kids on the
way to the whiskey to catch quiet riot
they will stop by
order their burgers
their smoothies yogurt whatever
i will take care of them then i will
pack it up grab my base and walk all the
way to the whiskey to do the gig
very humbling experience now okay so
you're in quiet right what were the
other bands in the neighborhood then
the bands like
who was out from them everybody
everybody that got signed in the 80s man
you know you had like motherly crew at
the time they were called london it was
nikki's band
london
and you had like uh
like uh the boys which is basically
uh
george lynch was in a in the band and
then you got dawkin like a version of
dawkins running around he had great
white cinderella no that's in there
always east coast east coast east coast
guys yeah yeah yeah so basically you
know we're talking about the west coast
sunset strip scene you know just just
about everybody that got signed in the
early 80s was still knocking around
in the in the late 70s
oh van gaal already gotten signed
they were already kicking ass out there
that were actually the last rock band
to get signed out of the la scene
before they shut the doors and to rock
and roll and start signing that's right
van gaal was around from 78. yeah
78. i'm thinking i'm thinking [ __ ]
toward it yeah oh yeah no they they yeah
they were out before that yeah they were
signed yeah
so it was cruel
yeah
quiet right well it was called london
london yeah yeah became the crew after
that yeah
and then guns and roses came lately
much later yeah you know i was uh i was
i was doing a band with tracy gunn so i
was getting my education of what
happened around the early 80s because
right now i'm talking late 70s
by 81 i was out of that scene even even
though i started you know i came back to
what is known as the mental health quiet
riot uh
i really didn't gig around town because
i was playing with aussie i went from
aussie to that band
we made mental health the record and
then we went on tour so it wasn't like i
was a all again you know beating
beating the you know the sidewalks you
know going from the whiskey to the
gazarys and the roxy and all that no i
didn't do that
we released the record and that same
week in march of 1983
we did four shows on two nights at the
roxy and that was basically uh in
addition to perkins palace which is not
really considered a strip show because
perkin pals was in pasadena
glendale around there we did a show
there for rock and roll tonight
you know that tv show
yeah that they had on friday nights yeah
and
outside of that uh
let's say when we played um at
when we when choir riot played at the us
festival this was that was like the only
other
la area show that we did
you know we weren't really a
once the album mental health was
recorded we were not a local band
anymore
so when dos festival came that was 83
correct yeah 83. you played with
quiet right yeah okay
i got proof
no no no i'm just thinking i got videos
just thinking about yeah the aussie
situation yeah where was it by that time
oh i i i left ozzy right after i
finished recording uh uh
speak of the devil the black sabbath
re-recordings at the ritz in new york
i left the band
yeah and finished the
mental health record
okay yeah so you stuck around that long
after randy passed
yeah i had a commitment i
had to finish you know the tours and we
had this this recording of
speak of the devil
to fulfill you know i wasn't going about
to walk out on them you know who was
playing the guitar and speaking of that
one uh brad gillis so he did do
speak of the devil yeah and then after
that who replaced him mike
vivian jackie lee jakey lee okay that's
what it was yeah okay
holy [ __ ]
right around
speaking of the devil was why just that
was it
that was it for me i just went into a
different [ __ ] zone in my life
i remember having speak of the devil and
but that was it it wasn't uh i think i
was done with uh diary of a madman
mm-hmm after diary of a madman i went
out i became my own [ __ ] mad man yeah
i'd have time how old were you then
like i was saying when all this went
down with you guys when everything went
down
like
i i you know i grew up listening to
spanish music
okay like when i was
in 1971 i saw that movie about the funny
all-stars and my head exploded
i never ever ever liked rock music
like when i was growing up i always
thought
you know all that [ __ ] you know you're
raised a certain way if somebody has
long hair yeah
and so early on i started listening to
like
the funny all-stars cellular crews that
[ __ ]
you know like i would go to kids houses
and they'd be listening to some [ __ ] and
i'm going like hold on let's play this
[ __ ] and their parents are coming in the
room you can't play this music in our
house you like that like i was always
two three years ahead of the other kids
there was a kid who came into the
podcast once i grew up with
that said he says i still remember you
bringing richard pryor into my house and
our parents catching us and you won't
allow the house anymore you know i was
always one of those dudes like my music
was
three years ahead of what everybody else
was listening to but
when i moved to jersey that's when i
first heard peter frampton
frapton comes alive
and i was like wait a second there might
be something there
maybe i'm being stupid and a new young
crazy horse
and i was like that's okay
i think neil young has short hair
i can live with that if he's got long
hair then i really can't run with him
and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
but i got led zeppelin something by led
zeppelin made me blow and then that was
it
and then i went to my friend's house
and i don't think we were smoking pot
yet but he played
tomorrow's dream
by black sabbath and i [ __ ] my world
up i was like i don't know about that
music but that [ __ ] was good
and i had deep purple when we rock we
rock we roll we roll
i started dabbling in it
and one day we were doing something and
i had to walk home and bam what do i see
this place isn't even there on one
berger land that we know in 17 street it
was like a little corner store next to
where uh uh
kentucky not kentucky fried chicken
don't cook tonight called chicken
delight where's it was right next door
to it and there was the cover to
sabotage
and i said what a weird [ __ ] album
cover let me buy that thing
and i took it home and i heard the
thrill of it all and i was done
then i heard hole in the sky mega mania
and i was done i was like what the [ __ ]
is this
i gotta start smoking some marijuana now
oh wait a minute you weren't smoking
then no no no i was dabbling in it
i would go out once a month with my
friends and take a hit off a joint and
put visine in my eyes and cologne in my
mouth and
you know the whole [ __ ] thing i
didn't know it was for music
and then i started getting into savage
not not really i started getting into uh
sabotage a little bit and then i bought
the second one
war pigs paranoid oh yeah and then i was
going down the jersey shore
for a rendezvous with my friend stinky
and john bender
and he everybody had to donate something
so he brought the cold cuts i brought
the weed and the music
and i brought the first black sabbath
down there
and it was just [ __ ] blowing our mind
john bender didn't like music he would
drink and pass out
but me and the other guy was sitting
there
and then
what would you do would you just sit
there like like i'm like a [ __ ] just
sit down like yeah i didn't play air
guitar i didn't bounce around i would
just sit there blown away by the lyrics
i didn't know what the [ __ ] he was
talking about man
you know uh it's really weird i think
when you're spanish
and you hear american a certain type of
american it makes you go crazy like it
just impressed me like when i first
heard richard pryor rudy i lost my mind
i came from a house where they cursed
and [ __ ] in spanish but i never heard
nobody curse like that in that context
you know what i'm saying like that it
blown my mind
so when i heard led zeppelin like i
wasn't a beetle dude growing up [ __ ]
that noise
i was from a part of jersey that you got
to be a sinatra dude
like the part of jersey i'm from sinatra
smacked the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] bruce
springsteen i don't know nothing about
bruce springsteen
but
i started going to concerts i went to
see aerosmith with ted nugent
that nugent was great era smith was god
awful rudy
god awful 77 god awful heroined up
they broke the guitars
why are you breaking the [ __ ] amps
for you guys need more practice than
anybody i've seen in my life before but
i loved again i had rocks
yeah i had rocks and i'm like god damn
this is a good out
and then my buddy talked me into going
he goes you know black sabbath is plains
and i was a freshman in high school
it was black sabbath with van halen
and in those days you didn't go for the
warm-up act you knew to get there at 8
30. like we ain't going for the [ __ ]
warmer back
but the rumor was to make sure you went
for the walmart act
and we saw it in front of us bill ward
was breaking apart doing blow
ozzie was fat
he had a gut he had a bottle of vodka up
on stage
it just wasn't there you didn't have to
be a
a music critic to know something's not
right here you know at that time i had
gone to six concerts maybe
i didn't know nothing about music that
much
and then
they broke up but i like never say die
and they had done something on don
kirschner's or the other one that was
really good for never say die
and i liked it so i like never say that
then they broke up but i started getting
more
more and more into ozzy
and then
like my sixth name after my mother died
that february i went down uh 22nd street
in new york avenue and i bought a 10 bag
of thc crystal which was basically
[ __ ] gorilla biscuits
aka angel dust animal tranquilizers
me and this other dude and i went and
bought [ __ ] master reality
on the way home and i went home i was
living in my friend's house he was out
on a date
i locked the room i put master reality
on and the exorcist was on and i put the
exorcist on with no volume listening to
master reality on that [ __ ] gorilla
biscuits and rudy says i thought my
heart was gonna blow up so i just turned
off the tv and never listened to master
reality until about eight years later if
i went to a party you put master reality
out i'd leave it's like when i hear the
music from star trek i have a heart
attack
that the beginning of star trek i got to
leave the room the old star trek the
original i don't like that music
what don't you like about it i don't
know it just scares the [ __ ] out of me
all right
i don't know what it is about the
beginning of star trek
it [ __ ] my world up
oh my god
how old were you when they came out
who
you the this has the star wars movies i
have no [ __ ] idea
star trek not star wars you're [ __ ]
okay the tv show
oh okay but when ozzie
that whole thing blew up
my mother had died i was out every day
partying with my friends and i just hang
out with a dude named john crowley
what a [ __ ] small world
and john crowley
listen we were at a movie theater once
in fairview
you know what fairview is they when we
were kids there was a carvel there and
there was a double movie theater and
every saturday night they played the
rocky horror picture show
and a concert movie neil young this song
remains the same
whatever
we went there once and there was a line
for the sewing remains the same or
whatever the [ __ ] we're gonna go see
i go john
we gotta cut this line john goes let me
do it when we walk to the door there was
an ice cream cone that somebody was
eating that they put it upside down and
ants on it and [ __ ] and it was already
melting
this [ __ ] picked up the ice
cream cone with the ants
and then the front of the line started
eating the ice cream cone they let them
cut in
nobody said two words to them you
understand me
we get into the movie theater and before
the movie's about to start i go john
go up to the front there and talk to
these people tell them what's going on
here
rudy he would do it
he would get
up and go to the [ __ ]
to the [ __ ] uh front of the movie
theater and say can i have your
attention please ladies and gentlemen
and we'd be in the back oh yeah
howling
nobody did with this the balls this kid
did we went to a party one time nice
white people
family
and i said really you got a chair
crowley got a chair they had a
chandelier
he [ __ ] got a chair
and he got he stood up on the thing and
he pushed up the chandelier i don't know
how he did it another time we're going
down the jersey turnpike in the truck
and he tied a string around his dick
and played with his dick the whole way
down route three people were [ __ ]
swerving from how f how have they were
laughing john crowley was crazy
so at this time in my life i hung out
with john crowley for entertainment
purposes
john crowley would take his dick out
he'd chase women naked whatever you
whatever mission you gave to crowley
when he had three beers in them and a
couple hits a wee briefer so i'm at the
end you know what he does today
he writes children's books
he hit me up on fate and myspace about
10 years ago you got to help me in
hollywood i got these books i can't sell
them i did the original music crowley
you're [ __ ] crazy
when that song mr crowley came out
that was adding gasoline
that was it
he loved ozzy osbourne
so by him singing mr crowley so i i
wasn't at the palladium show with him
the other show there was two shows like
you said
they threw him out
because he took his id and went up
backstage
and he said he's singing about me
let me in there
i got to talk to him and they escorted
him out and that was the end of john
craig that's a true [ __ ] story you
thought john crowley so he thought mr
crowley was about him
so he was crazy all along and a state
champion wrestler he was crazy all along
now ozzy threw the kiss of death on him
so everywhere he went people would sing
to mr crowley he said well be on my
local compiler
it was [ __ ] crazy when i went through
with that kid for three or four years
yeah that reminds me how insane our
audience was insane
you know well
the bad the bat the best threw it right
the [ __ ] over and it was a real bat you
know we you know we thought hey it's a
toy bat you know rubber he that's why he
put it in his mouth you know it was a
real freaking bat one time we were doing
a show in lubbock and this is in love
with texas this is right after he pissed
on the alamo so we were like on you know
on the lookout because the
the daughters of the revolution and
texas militia were threatening ozzy to
shoot him on stage you know so we kept
every time he would walk you know during
the show on stage he would walk over
towards us we would like run away from
him because he i don't want to get shot
you know
because we thought he was going to get
shot on stage right so i'm doing the gig
and i'm like looking around i was like
really you know aware of everything that
was going on you know it wasn't it
wasn't about getting into the music
anymore it was all about about surviving
the show you know not dying on stage
and i see this frog i thought somebody
was throwing a baby
at me on stage there was actually a
bullfrog
huge bullfrog it just landed right in
front of me
you know upside down with his arms
spread open and legs you know i freaked
first you know because in the dark you
don't know what it is so you look and oh
it's a freaking vlog i thought somebody
threw their kid on stage you know
they used to i
show up with freshly slaughtered
heads of cattle
trying to get into the gig with that and
of course they won't let them so you
know our roku would take polaroids
and
bring them backstage and say oh check
this out
what this
idiot was trying to bring in into the
show people are still sneaking [ __ ] in
because somebody threw a bat on stage
somewhere yeah they're bad yeah and like
a rabies i go up my shoulder oh what the
[ __ ] yeah the head of the of the cow you
know
it's completely [ __ ] it's too big too
big
with horns and blood dripping and [ __ ]
you know but then of course you know we
used to have the the dwarf that's the
little person
john
that
was part of our stage you know
presentation for the diary of amendment
tour so he had a bucket that he would
drag across the stage while we were
playing paranoid
the the the last song of the set
and they would put anything in that
bucket anything that was left over food
from the uh from
from dinner crew crew meal they would
stick it in that bucket and then the
dwarf will go across the stage throwing
it at the audience
slowly
and
whatever went into the audience the
second half of the song came towards the
stage and i got hit many times by
pieces of liver
uh gizzards tribes
you name it you know and some sometimes
they would if they didn't have enough
delhi you know
she had to put in that bucket they would
send somebody out to get some from the
uh
the nearest supermarket
and a lot of times it didn't thaw out in
time so still be frozen
one time the uh
john the little person he got knocked
over
by a piece of frozen liver
that somebody threw back from the
audience he just knocked him over on
stage and just they took him over to
emergency and stitch him up
right on his forehead oh yeah that's
crazy because when i swing into
palladium it was just
four dudes on stage when i went to the
meadowlands to see you when you guys
came back in october yeah after randy
had passed yeah
it was brad gillis but now you had a
[ __ ] castle or some [ __ ] behind you
yeah it was a different [ __ ] show
yeah and the crazy thing was for all my
aussie things i always had good tickets
but when i got there something happened
that the ticket became better
that was the only show that i had to
stay like where i was at i was like in
12th row so i didn't get hit by the
[ __ ] midgets yeah i didn't even know
he was drawn i don't even remember
well you know it was a little guy so his
throw was only like maybe five rows
because you got the pit and you got the
rose you know but you were sealed you
know everybody docking right in front of
you you know
you're using like the horrified faces of
people going like ah
and they would duck every time he would
throw something out in the audience yeah
now again in 1970 something some [ __ ]
[ __ ] went on david letterman and i ate
a bicycle what oh he ate a bicycle or
some [ __ ] he ate a pedal he did
something
and went on david letterman and he ate
uh yeah okay so now
sicker three years later i'm at this
[ __ ] party and this dude comes down
we played hooky and we ended up at his
house and this dude comes down
and he he uh before that i i'm going
forward the one party we went to he took
a gun out
his father was a cop he took a gun out
he brought it down they started playing
russian
and we all got up and left we were like
this out great bro i grew up in northern
new jersey with white dudes that were
the real deal you know and they and each
one wanted outdo each other
so the second time we went over there
was the dead of the winter and we went
to his house and
said john don't put the gun out there
all right i promise in those days we rob
a beer truck from kennedy boulevard
and we bring the beer to his house and
so we're like
i was he i was way younger than john i
was a freshman when this happened and i
went over there one day and his mother
smoked in the patio
but they had a little french poodle
and he used to take those little shits
little french poodle shits but they
wouldn't sweep it up they would just
freeze and stay at that taco
you know what i'm saying so you just
have to go out there and kick off the
little shits and one time we're out
there come in they were talking [ __ ]
and he goes how much would you damn it
eat a piece of [ __ ]
and we're like god you know we he got
like seven dollars and he picked up one
of those french poodle pieces of [ __ ]
and he ate
so now this became an epidemic where i
grew up now people were doing [ __ ] now
my junior year in high school
six of those morons get dressed up as
garbage
tremendous
they got garbage cans rubber garbage
cans cut the bottoms off they put
underwear on they put suspenders to hold
the garbage cans and then they put a lid
on their head
but to top it off they took strings and
they tied it to mail to little mice
tails
and then they took bags and they super
glued it on their head and they walked
in this halloween party each with six
live mice
this is 1980 80.
wait this is a year or two before
ozzie's biting [ __ ] off
these guys in the middle of the party
pick up the mice and start eating the
[ __ ] mice alive
tails are in their mouths a friend of
mine whose birthday is today mike ronnie
who i lived with after my mother died
grabbed one of the mice
popped in his mouth and was eating it
and you can see the tail so they all
started eating mice and this [ __ ] so now
my whole town is going crazy people are
eating [ __ ] i went to another party one
day and there was a table with a hammer
with glass they were eating glass these
[ __ ] did these white [ __ ]
became crazy and i love them i grew up
with them they're my brothers what am i
gonna do what now [ __ ] what do you
think happens ozzie's gotta because my
town loved dazzy osbourne
my town was sixty percent black sabbath
this [ __ ] gotta go buy the
[ __ ] eagles head off and now my
town's looking to [ __ ] eat dogs and
[ __ ] cats and [ __ ]
so ozzy osbourne [ __ ] us up in more
ways than one that thing that i'm
telling you about the mice
they not only did that they did that in
front of a hundred people in a school
auditorium on a halloween party for the
families girls were crying teachers were
running out
it was classic [ __ ]
classic [ __ ] they talked about it for
years like that they did that never
again that they have that party like
that was the end of the [ __ ] part so
that's how much
damage ozzie osborne did then he put out
snow blind
which [ __ ] sent you over again you
know what i'm saying
thank god nobody paid attention to
suicide solution one kid steve bancini
he went to the george washington bridge
he got a carvel sunday
he was blind steve banchini would see
you and he would say like quotes to you
like uh rolling thunder
power and rain i'm coming down like a
hurricane that's a verse from satanic i
don't know if it's that one
he would pick any song and he'd start
dropping knowledge on you and one day he
said [ __ ] it he got an ice cream's cup
ate it took his glasses off and he
jumped off suicide bridge he's like how
old he didn't blame him ozzie osbourne
on his family
the memories
of
rudy was that similar to your high
school school experience
oh my god it was made
no
my high school experience all i wanted
to do was to get laid that was this is
all at memorial all four years uh one
year memorial and then i went down to a
miami high okay
you know
and this is the 60s and i was overweight
in the 60s so that was like a you know
i might as well i had some kind of
disease you know
it wasn't like not even getting late
people you know chicks didn't want to
hang out with me guys didn't want to
hang out with me because the chicks
won't hang out with them because they're
with this guy you know who's like maybe
50 pounds overweight you know and all it
was is i was eating cuban food
you know my mom was making you know
cooking with lard eating a lot of rice
and i happen to be one of those guys who
is carbo carbosensitive it's the uh
politically correct [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it
does you know cars yeah yeah it does
still does you know but back then i
don't know as a matter of fact i we were
living in new jersey and
my mom heard about this diet doctor
happened to be one of those doctor feel
good type guys
i was going to memorial high then so my
mom and dad take me to this guy in the
city
and
they put me in you know take me to a
room and it's kind of like i went
through like separate tables one of them
took my blood pressure the other one you
know
blood tests and my weight and then at
the end they gave me these bottles and
say okay you take this one you know in
the morning then take this in the
afternoon then take this in the evening
blah blah blah right they were operas
and downers basically i had no idea my
parents didn't know they were just
desperately trying to help me
to cope with something that was socially
unacceptable at the time now nobody
gives a [ __ ] you know but back then in
the 60 was the whole you know mad men
they were they weren't they weren't even
fat people in in the whole show i kept
looking for one you know in mad men's
show and i couldn't see a find a fat
person because that's the way it was in
the 60s you know and
so i started taking these operas on
downers and i was screwed man
i would go to
the mornings i would be like
you know i was like like puppet running
around this chubby pup puppet and gym
shorts you know at a gym you know that
we had early in the morning we had the
uh fizzette
then in the afternoon it was kind of
like going down
and they gave me another upper
and by the evening it was the downers
that i'd so i couldn't do the homework i
i couldn't function i spent the whole
day
going up and down you know
and so i told my mom and she said well
screw that so she got me of that but
i gave it a shot how long did you stay
on them for uh maybe a week or so
it was it was terrible awful there was a
doctor in west new york or weehawken
when i was a kid
i didn't like needles so
somebody came to me once i go if you're
heavy you go see this doctor gives you a
couple shots and you lose
50 pounds
and i was like are you [ __ ] crazy but
then i have another friend of mine
that got high one night we were talking
and she goes you know my sister used to
be 100 pounds overweight
she went to a doctor for treatment he
gave her a bunch of shots so
it's something that you got to pay a lot
of money for
who the [ __ ] knows yeah
yeah it was taboo in the 60s to be a
little overweight all right yeah
yeah girls still don't really like it's
not like girls loved it now and when i
went to high school
it's uh
it's it's always been terrible
i think i think i might be alert i went
for allergy testing when i was really
young and i think i'm mildly allergic to
wheat and all that stuff so i probably
should stop eating bread and
all that yeah well actually i'm i'm
gluten free now and it's really helping
with with my allergies
really yeah yeah even though i just had
a bunch of gluten in that box but it's
not something i eat every day you know
that that's going to go out what's
gluten in that potato uh
no it's not the potato it's all of the
other wheat all the wheat stuff in it
you know like oats and wheat and barley
like if you drink beer there's a lot of
gluten in it you know it's not for
everybody it just works for me you know
and i'm not a celiac neither so
i've seen have you seen dean delray
lately
it's been a few months he looks
beautiful really he eliminated sugar
from his diet
yeah okay i think that uh
you know you hear about all [ __ ]
diets
but i think that right now that's a
popular one it's working for a lot of
people i have another friend that got
not diagnosed with cancer yeah two years
ago well he looks beautiful i just went
home and saw him and gave him a hug
and he goes all i did was eliminate
three or four things from my diet
sugar being the number one thing
and he goes i'm stable the treatment's
taken i'm alive i'm breathing i'm
working i'm working that i'm eating good
he goes with that sugar once you get to
a certain age it's not even good and
you'll see the difference
immediately yeah immediately but sugars
and [ __ ] everything rudy that that
period that i'm talking about you know
in the 60s when i was overweight
you know going through a cuban diet
everything had sugar in it
everything you know everything that was
that i that i consume has sugar you know
and if it didn't then you added the
sugar
my parents i mean my my mom
still adds a lot of sugar to anything
you know let's say if you have a cafe
con leche over the counter and the and
it's sweet already it's ready to go no
she's got to put a couple more sugar
you know packets in it i always had a
big i see it in my daughter now
i see the pickiness or maybe everybody's
children is picky with their diet
but i see the different [ __ ]
she's attracted to
you know it's good she likes pasta you
know she likes hot dogs i give her sad
bread hot dogs i keep it in the family
um she likes mac and cheese my wife
makes it fresh for her at least it's not
out of a [ __ ] box the school wants
the little lunch cups and it makes me go
[ __ ] crazy but
uh
it's so weird how i i was fine until i
was around 10 or 11 rudy
and then at 11 i got hooked on ma
with electrical nissan
that's and that's condensed milk the
[ __ ] that comes in the can
cubans drink it with a soda called mate
yeah and it's
very healthy for you believe it or not
it's
something like that yeah and it's made
of these [ __ ] herbs and it's pretty
[ __ ] good for you but not with
two fingers of condensed milk
every night before you go to bed yeah
like i did it every i got addicted to it
yeah i had to go home and do it every
night and i watch the honeymooners and
the odd couple and they would zap me up
and then by 12 30 i'd not be nunu
and one day i was like 12 or 11 and a
half and i was fat as [ __ ]
and i and this was going to karate
like i was a karate buff at that age
like something had happened to my body
like drastically
and also i started playing basketball
and i started jerking off and that [ __ ]
went right off and i got really really
skinny and i was like okay so i went
through a phase
it just didn't stick around by the time
i got to the seventh grade it was gone
yeah it was right before what cubans
call it
this arroyo yes
it's called when you start getting hair
and yeah
you start coming and you start getting
the deeper voice yeah right right then i
do you heard it i dropped 60 [ __ ]
pounds and that stuff was gone yeah i
was playing basketball and it didn't
come back till i was 30 [ __ ] eight or
some [ __ ] you know 30
36 or something until i moved to los
angeles
yeah yeah going back to the leche
connect you know that was a staple
in my family we had that a can in the
refrigerator everybody has a can with
aluminum foil on top of it and you just
like with two holes yeah i would never
drink it i would never drink it i don't
know like well you could put in a spoon
too yeah oh jesus christ no you never
did that oh that's the best that's the
best a pulso and what does it taste like
what
tastes like having
sweet milk yeah
awesome
oh yeah jesus
it's like caramel taste yeah yeah that's
that's not to go no no no no
i wouldn't and i don't like uh yeah oh
dusa de leche you know those little
pastries do so it's the same thing it's
like a condensed milk but into like a
brownie
los tre leches
you know those are the portraits you
know desserts all of that see i grew up
with matthias
yeah which is that'll kill you yeah
that'll [ __ ] kill you yeah that's
eggs sugar and butter whipped cream with
cinnamon on top of it and more [ __ ]
sugar yeah
flans i'm a flan dude i'm gonna you dude
my favorite my um
listen my number one
went with my mom i never had it after
she died it's not the yeah with
enterman's pound cake and that
[ __ ] and you let it get cold for
a little while and you put the cinnamon
when you pull it out come on now come on
now merengue
i wasn't allowed to eat my thing it's
white so i would everyone else get me
sick i'm not a menenga guy i'm none of
that
i'm an atheist
i don't like cream cheese yeah i like
cream cheese on my bagel with lox i like
cream cheese yeah yeah i just listen
another way to get fat is wayaba with
cream cheese a cracker after every
dinner whatever you eat for dinner at
the end of the dinner buy yourself the
long way ava and get yourself a thing of
philadelphia cream cheese and get cuban
crack if you want to gain weight
listen if you're skinny as [ __ ] i can
hook you up right now i got the diet for
you right now rudy and i are going to
talk about the cuban diet all right
the cuban diet consists of you open up
with not a cup of coffee or not uh
when you go when you're at a starbucks
so what's the big one
the grande listen that grande cafe
that's what cubans piss on their first
piss
my mom had a tub
it was a metal tub
that that's all she used for coffee it
had to be 20 ounces before anybody ever
thought of drinking 20 ounces but here's
the weird thing it was that [ __ ] that's
really sweet yeah that [ __ ] will kill
you
people drink an ounce of that and see
the devil
you follow me i did that every day oh
god i did i swear i did my my breakfast
was nec cafe
you know okay which is instant coffee
with one of those tumblers that you're
talking about but this one this was a
glass because i wanted to see
the sugar that i would pour in it kind
of like you know get to the bottom it
looked like an aquarium you know when
you have like the sand and the aquarium
with the fish swimming you know so it's
kind of like that effect so once it
collected like around maybe half an inch
of sugar in the bottom then i stir it
then i would take
uh
bread white bread you know like wonder
bread
and
low butter oh wait i'm getting to that
uh
this is this is the time where they came
out with uh with the uh with the liquid
liquid uh butter squeeze butter squeeze
butter so i used to make like designs
you know i used to get like you know get
creative with it make like little faces
and then i will fold it
and dunk it
and until it went all the way down to
the bottom
and then i was ready to go to school how
much bread would you eat in that just
one piece
oh [ __ ] loaf
a loaf of cuban bread with butter
dipping it in your coffee like an animal
and in between the eats drinking that
same coffee yeah because the butter
drips now stays into lee
20 pounds in one week guaranteed with
the cuban diet
that's the one division then the other
division is the steak
with the egg on it over rice
cut up with the yolk melted over
everything that's pure disgust with lard
with lard that's pure disgust
the lunches i really like
i like the lunches the lunches were i
like i like an avocado salad with onions
less
just avocado sliced thin yeah with raw
onions and vinegar and oil i like that
really a little bit of bread but that's
the side dish that's a sauce oh yeah
yeah that's not but tariff you know
that's a pipe that's what happened
that's an opener i took the five stars
we did today
my mom always had this theory that if
you're gonna be asleep for at least
eight hours you might starve so you have
to have una media
sandwich i bought one for my wife before
you went to bed
just to keep you from starving to death
and it's a little smaller cuban sandwich
a different type of bread yeah and a
little little pickle and a little pickle
so your body doesn't work that hard
because if you have a big meal dog it's
ridiculous how much how fat i could be
right now if i lived in union city still
it's [ __ ] crazy
i wish i was spanish of some sort it was
oh
you guys are amazing like the pork that
parker got with becky was amazing i
might cry when i tell you this story i
might [ __ ] break down because i've
been holding it for
i watched those eddie episodes of sally
and it took i realized i didn't lose my
mother i lost my mother and that world
i lost my cuban world yeah i lost my
cuban oil that there's a big thing when
you lose a world
i lost
people's houses that i could walk into
and i trusted their food i knew what
they cooked i knew what days they cooked
it on you know what i'm saying when i
knew i knew rudy's mom makes a little
body on thursday i'm gonna call i'm
gonna call for rudy and even if rooney's
not home she's gonna invite me in yeah
you know
i missed that whole thing but i'm gonna
tell you what i miss the most
and you don't know in your life what you
have until you lose it
my mom was what do you call those people
from cuba she was a waiter
that made it yeah that they made money
but her actions were wahida but they
were all heart which meant rudy
if you had to get up at eight because
you had to meet randy in rehearse
my mother would walk in your house at
three in the morning
really
but you know what i got to get up i
think oh yeah get up
they came over it too while you were
sleeping and made
fresh black beans and rice you know they
cooked the goat
they got a few steaks and they got um
garbanzo chorizo or whatever
and you used to be bothered like why
would you wake me up to do that
and you go downstairs and there was
cubans laughing there keeping music on
it's three in the morning but to them
it's two in the afternoon everybody does
this do you understand me like that stup
my mom used to come home from the bar
some night she was tired she came home
and gave me a kiss and went to sleep but
i'm like she'd bring six people over and
it was long goten chila at two in the
morning so at four my house smelled like
it was lunch time and she'd wake me up
and go i'm telling you another thing i
cooked
with yellow rice and fried bananas
there's people downstairs and i'd walk
into my kitchen at four and there'd be
six people drinking beers
eating
uh you know she'd make like cuban
crackers or prosciutto and [ __ ] and i go
jesus christ her and my stepdad would
have these parties at three in the
morning we called him come out you know
you just
and it went and it just lead this is not
just a salami sandwich
this is somebody who comes home at three
in the morning and makes
a four course meal
one meal is enough like my stepfather's
specialty was garbanzo freedom let me
tell you something you know many
arguments i got with him oh if i got
monster feet away what are you going to
make something different
today rudy right now i would give him
this hand
to have those garbanzo flavor
the way he would put the chorizo in it
he would cook it and that's clay
thing
lee
jesus [ __ ] christ
he put it with some frank's hot sauce at
any age if my if my stepdad made that my
mom would let me drink alone bro you
know i'm saying i can have a long bra
but as long as you have got bon sofrito
lango tencila or
during lent tamale in casuela when they
put the little lobster meat in there the
little ham whatever the [ __ ] that was
yeah docino oh my god lee you have no
how much weight does that put on you to
marlin consuela
i hate it
it's uh that whole lifestyle i really
after watching that show
it kicked my ass for a few weeks rudy
because i realized what the [ __ ] i lost
i lost a certain sense of humor
i lost a certain sense of
speaking to people
when you're in that realm i had my mom's
bar where i could go in there and i
could drop a couple of bean guys
eat my guy konya dumas
but the realm i hung out with
i had to walk in there and ask him for
that blessing
that's something that i don't i don't
live in that world
i was one of those guys rudy trust a lot
of choice no no no i had i was one of
those guys that was raised religiously
catholic but in cuban terms yeah so when
i came to your house i would ask your
dad for his blessing
there was no cocoa
those people didn't call me coco that's
what those other cuban people called me
but the kids i hung out with they were
decent cuban people the people i grew up
when they gambled they saw blow they
took numbers
they were nice people but i was involved
in two different worlds when i was a
young kid those geeky kids i went to
karate with from union city
that's how you had to speak in their
house
how those people in celia talk
come on tell me
you know when you go what do they say to
you on the way out the door those cuban
people it's a [ __ ] sermon
it's a [ __ ] sermon on the way out the
door lulu if you take leave
it's a five minute god bless you my mind
still does that it's like
it's like our goodbye is longer than our
conversations our conversation yeah the
goodbye and then god bless you
yeah you know my god
that's the other world i grew up with
that a lot of people don't know
i couldn't speak the way i did in front
of my mom's friends
in fact i had a family who threw me out
of the house
lord as ramos her mother asked me to
leave the house because i said to her
you're single you don't look too bad why
don't you go and get a husband she goes
nobody's ever spoken to me like that get
out of the house i was 12.
when did you say this to her after like
she gave me cookies
in the sixth grade i like this little
[ __ ] cuban girl oh my gosh so on
wednesdays we used to always i went to
school in north bergen so on wednesdays
we don't walk to union city
to get to be part of a pottery class
if i want to get in with this girl i had
to go up there and make a [ __ ] statue
every week with like a bunch of black
kids in the city that would bust up from
jersey city so it was me lourdes
it was uh this other cuban girl the
cuban girl i had a crush on and a friend
of mine would all go up there on
wednesdays and make figurines
and one day it was snowing us up and the
lord has invited us up and we went up
lotus was a cute a cute cuban girl but
she had a thick mustache
even in the sixth grade that
[ __ ] was yolk jack it was like
lee's mustache in the sixth grade
but she was cute and [ __ ] but nobody
had the balls to tell her lord is you
got to bust out the gillette you know
what i'm saying like no we had the ball
she lived on 26th street
in cali boulevard on the first floor
you couldn't break into a house unless
you were a gymnast it was one of those
first floors like it wasn't right there
off of kennedy boulevard but you could
call for her
and in those days nobody was having sex
guys at least i wasn't it was the
farthest thing from my mind
i just wanted to hook up with the skinny
girl and like make out with you know in
the sixth grade
as they called it yeah you want to make
out with them and hold hands and
but i never dreamed about having sex
with nobody in those days and the one
day i called for whatever we all went
over the house and i'm looking and the
mom was banging
if lourdes was 12
the mom must have been like 31 but on
fire
really she was on fire at that age i
looked and i'm like boy
i see the wenches that go to my mom's
bar you do great at my mom's bar you'd
walk out of there with three killers
what are you doing sitting home every
night with a bible i said you know i'm
looking too bad you might as well go out
there and shake it i'm burning like that
when they told me to get out of the
[ __ ] house
and after that i learned
the two types of humans
you know a couple years ago i still have
a great cuban friend his family is in
pasadena
and and i brought up
mom afro-cuban music to the house for
christmas
really they almost had a heart attack
rudy they almost had a heart attack
they don't like anything
black there's two types of cubans yeah
there's two types of humans and that's
the cuban i'm talking about
i always had that crazy cuban side i
could tell you you know i grew up a
crazy [ __ ] way
it was the kids i was involved with
and how i had to behave in that circle
those kids didn't get high
those kids didn't even think about
getting high we used to all go to karate
together and we were geeky kids and
three of them were going to join the
marines you know those are the cuban
kids i grew up with
it's [ __ ] crazy
god knows where they are now there's one
kid who
still talks to me he had a sex slave for
two years
me and him have been friends since the
bruce lee days
his father fixed
his motivator
around his name
his name is peanut that's the only
information the sex flavor of your
friend my friend's name's pino i know
pinot from sacred heart school for boys
because i went to sacred heart first but
then they put pinot in there first
because
his father had an air conditioning
business and he fixed my mother's air
conditioning at the bar
pinot's father did a couple bumps
everybody knew this so me and pino
became friends the front for peanut hang
out with his dad he'd have to come to
the bar me and pino would shoo poo play
pinball and go to bruce lee movies but
then me and pino ended up in the same
grammy school together me and pino loved
each other and then me pino and uncle
mikey like a [ __ ] kid he was like 19
when we were like 12 we'd let him hang
out he was a pervert that never made it
but he was a great kid mike he had a
basement and we could do karate down and
his mother would always yell at us get
the [ __ ] out of there you're a bunch of
losers
you never got about to nothing mikey
it was me
pino mikey this is a different period in
my life we studied karate
on 39th street and bergen line
at fuji pie academy above the bottom of
the barrel and carvel
bottom of the barrel lee is a big time
old school mafia bar where henry hill
hung out there
and the corner was carvel but what makes
this better was down the corner was
clutelentiocho
okay and next to him was dotocotina
okay but the secret about clemson
theologia was that it was owned by
willie randy
willie randy i told you this his claim
to fame
was that his grandfather was the dude
and godfather too had a big dick you see
godfather
you know yeah yeah of course yeah when
he comes up they take him to cuba when
he finds out alfredo betrayed him they
had a cuban joint where the cuban had a
big dick yeah well after that movie came
out willie von d's claim to fame was
that that was his grandfather and he had
a big dick too
so during the week he had bands and
salsa and menenga night but on saturdays
once a month it was willie randy he
would do a sex show in there by himself
we would pay off the cops nobody would
show up
like a solo act sex show i was probably
i'm probably [ __ ] 11 or 12.
i know i know nothing about this you
know what i'm saying like
i'm probably maybe 13 really you're
about to okay my stepfather edu
which means he was a bookmaker yeah and
his office was on 57th and
hudson
that's the heart of the cuban
neighborhood they had their blindy
they had another cuban bar that a
florist shop they had a butcher shop
these were all cuban-born these are all
cuban businesses but they were really
fronts for not drugs in those days
strictly numbers was that
union city or western new york west new
york so how far from public school
number five or or memorial was that
right around the corner from memorial
okay 56 is memorial is right around the
corner this is the heart of cubanville
there should be a cuban restaurant in
the corner the guy's named sister his
name was
and his sister ran that i mean great
cuban sandwiches great cubicle yeah yeah
i lived on hudson avenue hudson avenue
was the heart of cuba hey brindi was on
cafe
that was a bar on 52nd street cuban
bookie joint
then 57th street was it brindi and then
like into like 36th street was another
cuban little neighborhood there and the
guy's name was boyote that means sad
[ __ ] and he read that bar there
so my stepdad
lent money to [ __ ] this is hysterical
my my stepdad lent money to willie willy
vandy
right when he lends money for points
so one night i'm bitching about
something because in those days i went
to catholic school and i would come home
on thursday nights and i always wanted
to go to the movies but i did something
i was punished so part of the punishment
i got stuck with him and he didn't like
my mother's bar he would go early leave
and then come back and sometimes he
didn't come back so one night he goes
come on take a ride with me
and ice cream okay let's go charge the
money from willie rundy and i don't know
what's going on now at this time i knew
willie had a big dick
once i found out he had a big dick i
didn't really was his friend no more you
know what i'm saying like i'm i'm like
12. i don't want to be friends with a
guy's got a big dick what i don't need
that in my life
so
i take the ride to [ __ ] 38th street
and we there was no parking we were
gonna go get ice cream first but there
was no parking because that's friday
night saturday night and the hou and
that
that bottom of the barrel that mafia
joint was packed so we had a park close
to club 38
there was parking so
club 38 was on new york avenue so we're
walking up and we walk in there you
gotta like knock a certain way you know
like
and then somebody would knock back and
then you got a knock and then they'd
open it
they let you in and i was like you know
whatever
and i walk into the second comedy show
there's like 250 people
and they're standing there with cups and
everybody's drinking and they have like
cuban music on nobody's dancing and also
when i walk in with juan the lights drop
right there
the
it was just beautiful
and all of a sudden they bring like this
chick that doesn't want to be there like
she's like she's like getting raped but
not really no limit
no you know
and they tire around the pole and [ __ ]
and she drops their hands and knees
and then willie would come out with a
mask and like a cape and [ __ ]
and they were like and people like
oh lights would drop and sometimes the
bulb would go out because it was a human
dude he didn't know how to run the
lights and [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
craziness
and dog willie opened up his cape like
three feet away from the woman and he
started like shaking and gyrating his
hips and people were clapping
and i didn't want to look really you
know i mean rudy you don't want to look
at a man's dick but [ __ ] it you're there
you you might as well look it's right in
front of you willie his dick had to be
three feet long but it was like
it was like a tail a skinny tail but
here here's what i always thought like
for years it baffled me like how would
you get your dick that way
and then i watched anthony bourdain when
he went to cuba one time and they saw a
guy who was bending steel did you ever
see that episode
he's trying to bend steel and the one
cuban says
when i was a kid that was a big word
came out came
it wasn't no betty uh reagan that came
out and said don't smoke pot it was
cuban people that would tell you hey if
you smoke pot you're gonna burn out like
the beetles you're gonna get long hair
and [ __ ] what was i talking about really
okay without the
the guy with the steel the guy with the
steel okay so
i i thought about cuban people
and i thought about how this guy would
make his dick that big and i could
picture him and like three of his uncles
in cuba on the farm like since they all
had the reputation of having a big dick
like i thought about like this is the
only way
because you know how cuban people are
they all have a reputation of having a
big dick all those years like free and
they'll brag about it at parties
that they all got together and just
stretched it and just pulled down like
pull pulling you straight ah
ah and they just pull pull pull because
his dick wasn't naught like my dick at
the age was bigger it was thicker
his dick something that happened to it
like by the thing it became like a
little puss like a belly button and then
it was like they twisted it around like
a ponytail like it was dog i had never
seen that and it was not a prosthetic i
saw it with my own eyes after about a
minute or two dog i just ran out of
there crying and we went to carvel and
that was i never told nobody about that
story until about five years ago
oh my god oh my god
no i i i said the word quebrado because
like uh back in the day again in cuba
you know like if you force yourself
let's say if you pick up something and
it was too heavy you would get like an
una
which means that one of your testicles
would like blow up and get like really
huge and that was like a sign of being
carried out
i think you gotta hurt here right now
but it's been like that for so long [ __ ]
it
leave it like that why
why fix it if i ain't broken you know
what i'm saying that's the problem with
people is then you find other [ __ ] out
and you get mad at yourself
what's up lisa my brother
good to see you really sarso we ain't
saying no no
this is insane this is insane i love it
what's up buddy i just
did we finish up with the sex slave it
was just oh no pinot so pinot yeah
peanut butter what happened to peanut i
grew up with pinot till about
maybe the age of bruce lee died in 73 me
and pino were heartbroken
like we were heartbroken me pino and big
mike were heartbroken and i'm not
kidding you mike was like a 19 year old
something was wrong with him but he was
kind of there and he studied karate with
us all different all three of us went to
the same karate school
but they went to different karate
schools on the weekends or some [ __ ]
because they had mom somewhere else like
that their parents were divorced
so it was really interesting to hang out
with these guys growing up and things
happen and all of a sudden i did a
couple movies and one day i got an email
it's my man pino
and he's living in jersey he wants to
talk to me calling you i picked up the
phone this has to be
maybe a year after the longest yard i
pick up the [ __ ] phone peter what up
oh my god let me tell you what happened
buddy tommy goes you need something my
father done living the air conditioning
business
and [ __ ] i sold it and i made a few
million dollars and everything's
beautiful in my life he goes you need
anything and i go no you know
and he goes do you want to do breakfast
lunch and then i go i do let's do
breakfast tomorrow i go meet me at the
fort league diner so i meet him at the
fort lee diner
he looks beautiful he's still a handsome
kid never gained the pound he always was
a cuban that was tan with blue eyes sits
next to the table we ought to oatmeal
eggs bubba and then between the
conversation he goes listen man i don't
know if you're interested i have a sex
slave
i just she's been living in my basement
for years i got it tied up and [ __ ] he's
telling me this whole [ __ ] story
because in fact i got to bring her an
omelette you know
he's telling me all this [ __ ] and i'm
like
listen brother i can't i can't i don't
want to be involved he goes no it's all
legit
she signed
he signed paperwork i put away money in
escrow four
and in two years you know for two years
she belongs to me
i could [ __ ] her my friends could [ __ ]
whatever you want to do you want to come
over with your cook where's she from i
have no i didn't i stopped the
conversation rudy i didn't want to know
i didn't know if he was a fed you know
listen i meet you for breakfast you're
talking about a sex slave that's two
different [ __ ]
i meet joe from oatmeal and you start
talking about sex slaves you know me
rude i gotta ask her to check i can't
have that that early in the morning was
she with him on the leash no he goes i
was gonna bring you back to the house to
meet my kid
i go say how the [ __ ] he goes no no my
kid don't know it i tell my kid that she
can't go she's a tenant
only i'm a lot down there i got keys i
got to tie it up that's how she likes to
be tied up and all right
and that was it i didn't ask if she was
good looking i didn't ask what
nationality she was that had nothing to
do with me really was there like a
nuclear plant near your town like i
don't understand you're
it's like
a three-hour drive from where i grew up
and it just
couldn't be more different now
i went to
not miami fort lauderdale about two
years ago and he showed up and i asked
him you still got the sex lady because
nah the contract ended because she left
and he was howling
him and this kid were howling
unbelievable unbelievable
you know
do you think
all the crazy [ __ ] that happened in
alexillio
was a continuation of crazy [ __ ] that
was happening in the island or do you
think people just
lost it when they left the island and
all of a sudden they find themselves in
a culture clash
they know what you know they know what
the environment how to deal with it and
they just start like
doing crazy [ __ ]
you think that's what happened
to cuban people and yeah
nationality at least
i
i had a more outside of the box
experience living in new jersey than i
did when i moved back to miami which is
closer to
cuba you know it seemed to be a little
bit more
uh kind of like the same pattern
that we had living back in cuba in miami
but moving
to new jersey that was a whole different
experience
do you think that had a lot to do with
it for free for your experience being so
far away from
from the belly button now okay so now
here i am i'm living in
205 west adation my mom has a bar she's
successful she's got money at the time
my dad left the money
they had the restaurant up the corner
from willie randy to be honest with you
my mom had that up the corner from club
38 now today it's a refrigeration place
where they sell refrigerators for
restaurants that was a restaurant called
hello k
that my mom and my dad owned
in the 50s before fidel
it was a little restaurant they sold
cuban sandwiches cuban coffee and they
made money because it was
robert fulton what is it uh robert
waters
it was robert waters whatever that
school is right i mean right it's like
they owned listen to me it's like you
know that building across the street
right now lee right that's the high
school my mom owned the funeral parlor a
little coffee shop
and that was their front for the numbers
the numbers was their big thing
when my father got here he got here
before my mother
and he teamed up with these jewish dudes
and they started pushing heroin when
nobody knew this is the early 50s
because the
he spoke their language so he was the
interpreter
so he took a piece of that money and
started opening up businesses
he opened up that business then he
closed that he opened up a bar on 29th
street called every law
and that was bans a restaurant that was
the real deal
i mean two doors down from speakerman's
bakery those are the jews when you're
living next to jews you gotta be making
moves you know what i'm saying
especially in 50 [ __ ] though they
opened up the restaurant probably
61.60
oh that's
that's it
they had taken over this small little
piece
but at the same time cubans were taking
over a small piece
of miami
so in the winters i would spend them in
in new york city but the last week of
july
i would shoot to miami to 138th 130
100th avenue on the southwest by monkey
jungle
and this is a completely different yeah
kendall this was a complete different
world for me
my my godfather at the time was a
construction guy
he was a little league thing he was a
member of the chamber of commerce
he
he had two daughters and a son
very very successful
uh
newspaper articles he would take that we
used to when i was a kid i would get on
the [ __ ]
bulldozer with him
and i would see the [ __ ] lizards and
the snakes and the [ __ ] animals he
would go to that property when it was
still a swamp dog
and then they would lay the thing and
then he would build the first house and
then he moved into the first house
and while he lived in the first house he
built four more houses that were
duplicates of those houses it's gonna be
cena
you know a tremendous backyard with a
lemon tree an orange stream finca
whatever they called it and blant so you
had this big property so as a kid i
would shoot down there the last week of
july now when i went down there i go to
red berries baseball camp
and i live under my godmother's rules
which was no cursing
very religious
they didn't talk about what i talked
about up there
but rodolfo
i knew from my mom's conversations that
rodolfo was from the same world my mom
was from
so at night i would sleep with rodolfo
because him and vivian never slept
together anymore because he would snore
at night so he had a king-sized bed back
there so we would in miami in those days
this is
71 72 you're already in miami oh yeah
okay the tv was shut down at midnight at
one o'clock
but the last show would be mission
impossible
and after mission impossible
and the tv would shut off rudy saizo and
he would say coco
and me and him would get dressed and
we'd take a ride to a uh
a place that
and they would sell beers and milk and
butter
and it was a drive-through they still
haven't jesus christ lisa you understand
me lisa yet
and the beer was
leaked listen to me
it's freezing
the hotter it was lee outside and the
more humid it was that [ __ ] cuban
dude in that hut knew that beer had been
under ice for 12 hours lee you couldn't
even hold it it was so cold god and i'd
be 10 and he'd buy me a [ __ ]
budweiser
and i'd drink a budweiser with him and
i'd get a little drunk and [ __ ] and then
he'd take me down to some [ __ ] dock
and we'd get on a boat and he'd go out
and he'd pick up bales of weed
and i make believe like i didn't know
what was going on but i didn't know what
was going on he put him on the boat
and we'd drive back he'd lock up his
boat
and we'd drive back to the house like
nothing happened and on the way back he
goes you don't understand this between
me and you
my kids don't have to know nothing about
this
and then he would tell me stories about
him and my father growing up in cuba
with tony perez from the cincinnati reds
and now uh
when your dad died it broke my heart and
i had to move and
he would cry he would break down and cry
then we'd go back to his house
it'd be like 5 30 in the morning the sun
would come up we'd lay down for 10
minutes and vivian would make [ __ ]
eggs and bacon it was like nothing
happened
and i'd do my [ __ ] with the kids she
would make us do homework from nine to
ten that she would assign
oh no no no you had to play the piano
so it was two i lived i lived like an
undercover life a cuban undercover life
you understand me yeah i knew what was
going on but i didn't know what was
going on
and then he ended up shooting some dude
and everybody he went away to that land
and then his kids found out
i still keep in touch with the kids as
best as i can in fact i was thinking of
calling
the son today i was thinking about them
so
those are the cuban wells i lived in
but
all those families like i said those
early families the kids i grew up with
in union city
those kids showed me the other world and
how the polite they were
and how they couldn't speak that way in
front of their mothers you know what i'm
saying like i couldn't speak crazy in
front of my mother
but she wouldn't talk like regular moms
like i would never bring my mother in
public really
like i would try to avoid my mother
going to school as much as i [ __ ]
could
because she didn't know how to act
she was a [ __ ] wahida you know what
i'm saying and to make it worse oh i
hear that with money
with jewelry hanging off you saw this
thing today at the house
he saw the [ __ ] thing when i was
three my sister sent me a picture from
cuba of me and my mom when i'm in three
i got a suit on rudy that was your mom
yeah she was there holding me with a
mink hat on who who was a meg cat in
1966 you know what i'm saying
not even black people had a mint cat out
in those [ __ ] days and the chain
around her neck with the big [ __ ]
santa
and a tremendous gold cane like yellow
cool j who does the type of [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying i saw the ankle
bracelet and my neck has stood up
because when i was a kid no women had
ankle braces
she would have a gold [ __ ] bracelet
with like a thing hanging on who wore
that [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
so i grew up and all that stuff and all
those businesses
in those days were all cuban known rudy
and you had to behave a certain way in
those places you had to act a certain
way when you walked in those places
you couldn't be in there giggling and
[ __ ]
the other day
i'm flying
okay
and there's a kid
and there's a girlfriend
and i lee i thought of you i didn't
think of you in this way lee
i just thought of you because
i wanted to tell you on the podcast and
i forgot
because of where what culture i come
from okay
it's six in the morning okay i know it's
[ __ ] early but you gotta pay
attention people get shot every [ __ ]
day you gotta pay attention this kid and
this girl are [ __ ] around but
obviously they're with a guy
that the kids got to be i cap clock i'm
at 24. the girls got to be about 23 and
the old man's got to be about 60.
as we're walking i see that that the two
kids
are walking more and more distance from
the old man
i see the old man reaching his pocket
i'm walking uh slanted behind him
and he takes something out he goes back
he takes something out
and as we get to the tsa agent
the tsa agent goes
ticket and [ __ ] id
and by that point the old man walked up
with them he looks at the boat and he
goes
and i remember what that word meant in
my culture at that age tell them really
what it means eating [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
yeah you know it's eating [ __ ] really is
when you black out in life
like i didn't see the kid running from
out of the car talking
you were [ __ ] around texting you were
doing something you were not supposed to
even be doing
you're at my restaurant sit down
straight and look straight ahead
you don't need to touch nothing in those
days if you touch something they'd say
no dog
like if i would go there if i were going
to hernandez restaurant i wasn't allowed
to touch the condiments
he would tell me 10 times oh yeah don't
touch my condiments you don't need to
touch my condiments for no reason at all
i don't want you touching the sugar i
don't want you touching the salt
you're sick of a kids throwing away like
the way i and then pinot's pizzeria came
pinot's pizzeria was on 22nd burgenland
avenue a tremendous [ __ ] cheese slice
wait a second
is that pinot the sex slave no no
there's a complete peanut
that's why we would always go in there
with peanuts so many people when peanut
open we're going in with pino and
buster's with a real pinot please stand
up and then we'll get pissed off what
peanut full from ellie i'm pinot i'm
from cuba there's no italian named
peanut tremendous
then pinot's pizzeria open
listen you're gonna peanut pizzeria take
the pepper and throw it against the wall
and it was another day there you know
what i'm saying but up
you can go
yeah you can go in there and throw the
pizza and say [ __ ] you pinot and that
was another day in the life of those
[ __ ] savages but two blocks up at
hernandez
cuban restaurant
you had to act like a gentleman
because the old man
would [ __ ] [ __ ] you up and everybody
knew it he would [ __ ] you up he had a
reputation of dragging people down
bergen line and across the street was
the buster is
this is so [ __ ] crazy to me like how
talking to you brings all this out i
forgot when you walked into saying we
started talking about the palladium
i thought about
what i was going through in my life at
that time
and what seeing that ep meant to me at
that time
like my head blew up
and now i see you here and we're eating
and we're [ __ ] around it's
thanksgiving week
it's [ __ ] crazy really soon it's nuts
it's nuts
i'll never forget my my first sanctivity
in miami you know because you know
coming from cuba we we didn't have that
we had no children that was it you know
so sankivity was like and why does this
sangeethi is all about you know then you
get to know about the pilgrims and the
indians and all that right
but we were cuban refugee you know our
first thanksgiving was 1961. we had we
were fresh
fresh off the of of that of the of the
pan-american airlines flight
uh we landed in september october
november that's it uh two months later
you know right after my birthday you had
sanctivity
and so my mom you know we were getting
army surplus food at the time all the
cuban refugees we did which meant that
my mom every couple of weeks she will go
with with us the kids she will take one
of those
you know like the little cards that you
put stuff in you know
like your groceries or your laundry and
stuff and drag it down you know for
about four or five miles
to the place where you picked up the uh
the army surplus food it's kind of like
costco
but only for refugees you know
and they'll you know you go there and
you give them a card
that had like your allotment of how much
every you know every couple of weeks and
they fill these boxes just like costco
and everything is plain wrap
plain wrap powder eggs powdered milk
peanut butter government cheese
uh spam you used to call it cane de
refugio
and my mom learned to make kind of
refugee meat refugee meat
yeah i'm just trying to imagine what
powdered eggs taste like
powder eggs
next time you come on some of these tits
lick the white blue fluid that drips
that's powdered eggs right there butter
eggs
you know it's got to be it's american
airlines eggs
yeah like that or or the uh you know
when you stay in one of those hotels you
know you know
where free breakfast you know powder egg
eggs scrambled eggs you know stuff like
that yeah
and uh so yeah so my my mom had all of a
sudden you know
you know it was kind of like
how am i gonna feed my family with this
crap
you know but it was amazing you know the
cuban mind you just kind of like adapt
and be creative you know so she made
croqueta
refugio she made like hamburger patties
cane refugio you know everything was
refugee meat and you could always smell
it you walk down the hallways of a of a
you know a
project
you know miami will have big buildings
where you know a lot of families live
there
you know two or three story high you
know you could smell the cane refugio
you know cooking it i'm with lard they
gave you a can of lard you know and it
was totally insane
totally insane i can't lie to you every
time i go to wraps and i see
that can [ __ ] spam i i i might get
goosebumps because i want to buy it
cut it slice it then and fry that
[ __ ] with two eggs you have no
idea at least
you have no idea what happened you drink
a cup of coffee after that and don't go
10 feet farther from the bathroom you
understand me because your life's about
to flash in front of you yeah
spam spam spam is not bad
you know what i don't need it i haven't
even in years but
i could go buy a can of spam right now
get some spinach cook it up with some
olive oil with some garlic some [ __ ]
uh some spicy pepper that red crushed
pepper
and eat some spam and some spinach what
damn me go ahead but that's all we had
nothing yeah so no no the choice you had
spam kind of fool you you know yeah
you know now how old were you when you
left cuba rudy
uh was about two or three two and a half
months shy of 11.
and what do you remember like what do
you like
like i said
i grew up in a house
that i was too young to remember what
was going on
so you have this you have you have this
hundred
uh percent hatred
uh around now i know when i look at you
and i go i hate the boss in the red sox
no
when i look you straight in the face and
i go away i said you know sf
you know when i look at people looking
at that i grew up with that type of hate
for fidel yeah like it was [ __ ] ugly
spitting hate you know i was around when
they started looking for anybody who was
associated
with batista
like that's how hatred
humans were in 1970 through 75 i used to
hear rumblings
of these cubans looking for cubans
that have been involved with that were
now in their 60s that were involved in
the batista regime and now they were
going to hunt them the [ __ ] down
and i remember i told you there's a kid
i grew up with that they they put him in
the witness relocation plan he was one
of batista's drivers
and i remember going
would i [ __ ] leave an island and hunt
somebody down
even at that age with no logic
i was like that's [ __ ] hatred
but you know what by the age of 16 rudy
my mother died
other things were popping up i had
forgotten all about this hatred for
fidel
so whenever he was on tv now because in
the home i grew up with as soon as he
came on tv you gotta switch the channel
you gotta switch it right away and temp
is fled and sometimes somebody broke
down in tears it was ugly at that
[ __ ] bar i saw it a thousand times
the mood go from [ __ ] that's how much
hatred there was in the early 70s
towards fidel castro where i grew up
i don't know i forgot about this hatred
the movie scarface came out
and all of a sudden
i watched
the celia show and by episode 20 they
got to go to mexico
but fidel just turns on this country
and his hatred for [ __ ] black people
and his hatred for
uh gay people and
uh how he just took people's businesses
and put them on a [ __ ] pedium
and they had to have tickets for food
and you know celia cruz wouldn't look at
him in chiang gevara
you know they have that scene where they
told her make sure you sing that song to
fidel directly in che and nod and smile
and she wouldn't do it so they declared
her uh whatever of the state and then
she lost the house and they attacked it
it's very interesting
how what do you remember rudy
well growing up uh
well first of all my parents they they
originally we were gonna get on a on a
cruise that was bound for spain that was
going to do a layover in
new york city and the plan was to when
my family arrived on this and this ship
in new york city
to
to ask for political asylum you know and
stay over in new york well
the the crews right before the ones that
we were scheduled to get on
half the boat did that
they did that they just got off and
asked for politics out of new york city
so from that point on they say well
we're not going to stop in new york
anymore we're just going to keep going
from havana to spain wherever it was
probably barcelona you know
uh
so my parents had to like re you know
start all over again you know
we we had a sponsor that claimed us from
the united states we have visas we have
everything it was all legal you know
plus a passport
plus the danger of doing that in a
communist country because once you the
the powers that be find out that you're
leaving that also
[Music]
you know you you're leaving the country
you're leaving the revolution basically
you're not supporting the revolution
anymore so
my parents took my brother and me out of
school
for
that year
because in schools you know
the teachers were made to ask the kids
questions about how their parents are
talking about fidel and the revolution
at home
you know they were kept after school for
that
and
one of the instances i remember one of
the teacher coming in to you know to our
class and saying okay i want you all
kids to to pray to god
for ice cream
we did and we got nothing and then she
goes okay now pray to papa castro for
ice cream and
we got ice cream you know so they were
indoctrinating
our generation
you know
and turning us against our parents
and we were kids we didn't know what was
going on you know when you're a kid
you're you're basically honest you know
when they ask you certain questions you
know
especially when there's an authority
figure
kind of like threatening you you know
uh in school basically just their
presence would be enough to do that so
my parents wanted to avoid any
possibilities that was around the time
when they were doing le pione pioneritos
pioneers
which is basically they were taking kids
from families sending them over to
russia
and there was a
it was a movement that started happening
in miami called los peter pan peter pan
was getting the kids
out of cuba
and putting them in foster homes
around the united states
new orleans
miami certain other parts of the country
just to avoid from having the kids being
sent over to to russia
at the time
uh when we arrived in miami i mean i was
in havana when bill pigs happened and we
were in miami when the
october missile crisis happened
so i have a recollection of all of the
uh
the intensity in the air
that you felt you know because you just
didn't know you didn't know if it was
good you were
experiencing the beginning of a world
war three
you know it was really really thick
i'm being a young man i don't mean to
you know sex and everywhere you went had
a fallout shelter oh yeah
you know schools had the [ __ ] drills
yeah and you had to go down to the
basement and they gave you a package
then one day we asked down there for two
hours and they gave you a package and
they had tang
tang tang with water and like a [ __ ]
some [ __ ] artificial sandwich and
[ __ ]
and uh
we were more prepared like they were
preparing kids for war in those days
like we always had to go to a basement
or some [ __ ]
i didn't see it as war i saw the the end
of the world this was it and then what
was gonna happen let's say you came out
of that cave
to this new world where everything is
destroyed
what
what are you gonna do
you know
did you ever see castro when you were a
kid yeah i did where did you see him um
my dad used to work for la revuemia
he was one of the uh
of the technicians he ran the three
bobbin machine you know there was like
three big
cylinders of paper
and they would rotate and
the paper would be printed on that right
so yeah we worked at at the at the la
rita uemia for many years
and so he had a uh a
technician status technical
so he was part of the union and
everything so there was this guy miguel
anger quebeco
and he was you know he was a very
wealthy man and he actually supported
the revolution
so right after the revolution you know
when castro came into power he threw a
big party at his ranch for the employees
and for fidel you know
you know
uh
sofia was there and
and
so you know at that time he had not
declared himself a a marxist leninist
yet he was just fidel castro you know
revolution revolutionario you know
so you know it wasn't like like a real
scary situation because
you know things were
just this is right after the revolution
and then after that he started making
all those speeches and the country went
into in the whole different direction
and that's when [ __ ] became very very
scary
the first people that we knew that
actually left the country were chinese
that were
in our neighborhood you know the ones
that owned the
chino you know they had the uh the fruit
stand they had the chinese restaurant
the laundrom the laundry all of that
because they came to cuba from from
china
running away from communism
and when once castro come you know
declared himself a communist and said
we're out of here
and they just made out for
they live for san francisco you know
yeah in 1960 it was one of the biggest
china towns yeah
the chinatown in cuba i thought some
people stayed and fidel left them alone
supposedly i didn't know what was going
on you know i
i reconnected with my sister
and one conversation we had
we had a conversation about a time
period when i found the letter that they
wrote you know
and and i couldn't believe what i was
reading i could not believe the words i
was reading and i'm asking my sister how
was it being raised and she goes
it was all according to how much money
your mom sent that month
you know
and uh
like i just uh
i still remember like those years
where there was kind of when my mother
had to sell the bar
and she couldn't send as much money as
they they could that was one of the
letters they sent
and i asked my sister about it and she
goes you know
there was a time where they were just
turning
this whole island against you guys
she goes it was just terrible when it
was they were on top of us and then when
i met my cousins
for lunch dinner one night after i
spotted the improv right here on
they were telling me like what what it
was like to grow up and have to hide
albums
when they first got led zeppelin four
would stay away to heaven just
jesus [ __ ] christ
it's just uh weird to hear
it was really
eye-opening watching that cellular show
because
when i go to portland i'm gonna meet
with an attorney up there a friend of
mine a dear friend of mine
and maybe we can put this warrant thing
away and i can go to cuba and see my
sister because my sister won't leave bro
what the [ __ ] am i really doing really
i've never i haven't seen my sister
since i was three years old
i can't die and not see my sister
lee you're right over there you're over
there [ __ ] mumbling stumbling by
yourself everything all right over there
i'm doing fine i'm just i'm just it's a
it's a crazy country it's weird because
my my on and uncle are going next week
now for our vacation so now it's totally
open you should go with them and take a
hundred stars and just 200 stars for the
canadian tourist you know what i'm
saying
take a couple kilos do something
[ __ ]
let me give some shout outs here real
quick tom schwab
kern michael i love you
jeff teleman
newly won love alex castino hugo toppin
dr nick balovich
uki spooky
bob lalingus and his family
and the rest of the church goddamn
family i love you guys
happy thanksgiving
one thing before the show i asked you
about the
resurgence of music
the resurgence of music because
the music business has changed so much
over the last few years
that everything changed like they
started
not having record sales so bands had a
tour for the labels to make money is
that correct something like that
something
they're not making money off records i
don't know what i heard so no i i i make
the least from my catalog from from
record sales or even download i make the
most i mean from other sources streaming
sources or
um
right we actually now get paid
for non-terrestrial
performances on records that you are
signed to the record deal like for
example i was signed to all the record
deals for quiet riot
so i every time a quiet from from the
record from the from the mental health
record or conditioned critical record
the song gets played on the radio as a
performer
i make money on that
that that was not the rule as a
performer
and on the radio on the radio you know
non-terrestrial which means like spotify
sirius xm all that stuff not the the
ones with antennas
but you know computer satellite radio
and stuff like that
and
you know that's it it kind of like
balances it out it makes up for it
but i would say most of the income today
is not from catalog is actually from
sometimes getting your music placed in a
movie or television or advertising
and also for performing live
and vip meets and greets
and merchandising and that money is
actually allocated towards your your
cost your overhead for transportation
you know even if you have a bus or
you're flying or hotels or playing
paying for the crew and so on
it's not you know it's it's money that
you must make in order to break even or
make you know some sort of profit
but uh
over the years
you know when i was growing up uh you
went to see uh
uh
michael jackson four nights at the
meadowlands and he just did four at the
at the garden
for a couple years that live shows it
seemed like the numbers were going down
and all of a sudden i guess these
promoters put all these bands together
and said listen [ __ ] all this [ __ ] let's
get for you [ __ ] together and
take it out there old school yeah the
market's out there the market's out
there you know oh yeah absolutely and
you're active and you're [ __ ] uh
you're out there again and also in all
these bands these resurgency and i think
it's great you know bad company tour
this year like i said peter gabriel
toured with [ __ ] sting yeah that was
a great tour who would have thought you
know we were talking about how
poison and def leopards going out you
know
all these bands and i'm like your phone
must be [ __ ] ringing really
you know i'm i'm actually uh doing gigs
with a band called the guess who
you know american woman yeah
yeah and it's uh it's it's great i'm
having a wonderful time it's uh we do a
lot of civic auditoriums uh theaters
casinos
so
yeah
yeah it's not it's not a club band it's
a it's a classic rock
you know uh established group and people
will go see them yeah like people like
me would go what the [ __ ] let's go
american woman is one of my gems i'm
gonna jump out of the window absolutely
and i gotta tell you that the whole set
is packed with hits they had 17 hits top
40 hits
in their in their history and i'm
beginning to learn a little bit about
that about that circuit because
uh most of the bands that i play with in
the past have been you know what they
call 80s bands you know and that's
that's a whole different you know
hierarchy but the hierarchy with classic
rock bands for example we did a show
with with the three dog knight
so whoever goes on
the headliner is decided by who had the
most hits
three of the knight had like 21 top 40
hits so guess who we opened up for them
because we only had 17.
you know so it's that's the way that
they weigh things you know it's all
about how many songs on hit songs on the
radio you actually had
which makes sense yeah
[ __ ] it why [ __ ] around you know what
i'm saying yeah exactly the the this
yeah yeah but but the thing is if you go
to the 80s bands
no you know
i mean who had 21 top 40 singles from an
80s band
you know maybe a bon jovi maybe we got
close to that i would you know i mean
i'm talking about rock bands
because they were mainly result you know
we used to sell records albums and that
would be about two or three
singles or they weren't even singles
they were mtv videos
you know with white snake in 1987 for
the 1887 record we had four videos which
meant that we were able to tour for
about a year and a half on that record
because we first went out as an opening
band for for for motley crew then we
came back around again playing basically
the same market as a headliner
and then we that was in the winter and
then we did the summer tour and then we
went to you know europe and
asia and you know whatever so
it was it was a little bit different
that the classic rock bands it's based
on top 40
billboard hits
no mtv videos
you didn't have the liaison
another illusion i thought you replaced
two people together i'm singing chicago
yeah how many hits they got 40. yeah
they went through oh my god yeah i mean
but the singer's not there peter sater
is not there it's not there uh
actually they had three singers they had
the [ __ ] horn sounds tremendous
yeah i saw them do some hall of fame
show and they did uh
250624 or whatever [ __ ] off yeah
one section yes they have three lead
singers uh bobby lamb robert lamb uh
pizza tara and terry cath
and then they brought in another uh
another lead vocalist into the band you
know and
yeah it's it's all about the songs
you know
with that classic rock
you know market
i saw
somebody
one of those [ __ ] jerkos i have
yahoo.com
and i scrolled down one day and somebody
wrote uh
the top
touring bands
of a genre
without the original members
and you know me i'm a music guy rudy i'm
looking at this
and i saw the numbers they're doing you
know and if one guy left
you know uh with bad company i think
there was two guys from the original
band yes they were there was somebody
turned with nobody original yeah it was
something crazy the kid's son put the
band together his friends i don't even
know what the [ __ ] is going on actually
with that company it's up until recently
it's three members you have uh simon
kirk the drums uh mick ralph's on guitar
and paul rogers on vocals
who was the old bass player for that uh
bos burrell
i did a radio who passed away i did a
radio show in chicago with the guitar
player then yeah right nick yeah very
nice guy
but it's crazy how
i i read the article
i looked at it from the [ __ ] writer's
perspective
how he was trying to blow these people
under the water type of deal
but i looked at it from a different
perspective look at the numbers they're
doing
when i go see those guys it's about
nostalgia absolutely absolutely it's
about that song they did when i used to
finger bang that chick behind the
[ __ ] yeah carvel yeah in the dead of
the winter and the heat of the night the
the the
absolutely so i could see how for me i
would go to more of them i went to one
at the hollywood bowl
from the 80s with cindy lauper and
somebody else and somebody else
my wife got the tickets we said what the
[ __ ] you had the cab drop us off right
next to the joint so you don't have to
be walking up the hill from franklin you
know what i'm saying that's how you do
it you're abandoning this ship well how
you doing over there
i'm bringing you on your agenda the rest
of the day yeah the day's pretty much
over once this is done what are you
doing tonight
tonight uh i don't know
well i want to bleach your eyeballs
bring them back to the light look at
those things now oh my god yeah
see i told you in the afternoon you want
to mess around with uncle joey i'm like
the wu tank like you know what i'm
saying
maybe if i if i get out in time maybe
i'll go to a
rossita
what's a messina a black horse dark
horse oh that's right and i said
blackouts i got a spot at the store i
think okay cool i gotta spot the store
i'm gonna go home and hang out with the
family and stuff like that what's your
schedule looking like tarzan talk to me
are you with me yeah i'm doing the next
guest school uh in december
i believe 9th or 10th yeah we got three
more shows and they're basically in the
dakotas
because in the winter time that's
exactly where you want to be
you know we got three
listen when i go on where i go in the
winter i go in the winter there for a
reason
you know what i'm saying if you're going
to go there yeah if you're going in the
summer it ain't going to be the same
type of party yeah exactly you got to go
there when you go to buffalo you got to
go in january don't go to bed yeah yeah
that's right right that i'm telling you
this is my perspective that's true when
i go to new york city i go november or
september
i do that for a reason i don't want to
be in miami in august i want to be in
miami in october yeah yeah the dolphins
are winning everybody's happy you know
what i'm saying
uh there's certain places you want to go
at certain times of the year yeah uh
detroit you want to go to detroit in
january yeah if you're going to rock the
house [ __ ] if not
you end up like the singer [ __ ] it yeah
and that's true because uh early on i
learned you know from touring with ozzy
we used to do a lot of uh winter tours
and that was because there was less
traffic
less bands you know like if you go out
in the summer everybody's on the road
you're going to the winter time
everybody is back home you know resting
from having too much turkey after
christmas and and then you're out there
you're cleaning up because there's
there's no competition you know you're
you're the only game in town basically
but there's also a strategy for me
now today's economy
in today's economy once november the
second week of november starts i don't
fly eastbound
until mid-january
i do not touch lax till mid-january the
last week of january now
i have a thousand reasons for that
i don't want to be that [ __ ] because
every year we sit there
christmas eve full
it's over you're happy and you're
watching world news tonight and they
show you millions of strands millions of
airplanes stranded for the holidays
sleeping on cots
yelling at the [ __ ] lady of delta
yeah so i made it a [ __ ] habit
the first week of december
is it for me number two i'm an r-rated
act they have a lot of christmas parties
starting the second week of december why
[ __ ] around why take a chance you know
what i'm saying the club owners are very
nice to me i understand
i get it
the week for me to go back is december
26th that's when satan comes out that's
when everybody wants to get that dick
sucked they got a new pair of socks
they got new pair of pants that's an
uncle joey shows up to your town that's
a good week but i'm very lazy now really
i'm scared of flying with snow and
delays and all that [ __ ]
then the holidays makes people crazy
there's always a plane that goes off the
track it's [ __ ] o'hara right the
train can't the plane can't stop it
takes the [ __ ]
it takes the [ __ ] burger king side
down and left field
you know why be a part of that kennedy
airport gets crazy you want to go home
for what to do what to make two thousand
three four thousand it's not worth your
life
it's not worth being stuck in an airport
for a day and a half it really isn't you
know i'm saying mom i love you i'll see
you the last week of january with a
bigger gift than i was gonna get you in
december because it gives me two weeks
to clean up that visa card you know what
i'm saying and i can start all over
again
that just for me i don't like those
weeks yeah right now i go to portland
next week
and the party's over i go to portland
december 1st 2nd and 3rd
and when i come back right and i go out
of burbank oh yeah that's it i was like
yeah and i fly back into the burbank and
that's the last time because you also
need to you don't need a break from
travel you also need a break from
airports
so that'll put me in like seven weeks i
don't see a [ __ ]
airport that gives me a complete break
and i'm not flying in the danger zone
time of the year listen don't get me
wrong a plane could go down in the
summertime in october november that's
not what i'm scared of
i'm scared of delays i'm scared of
uh last week lee and i had a drive from
boston to connecticut and i didn't think
about it till i got back into my bed
that night how much that bothered me
that night
i don't like driving with strangers
really sarzo
something doesn't click on me if that's
[ __ ]
i don't want to be a movie star i want
to drive the [ __ ] car you know what
i'm saying
i don't know who you are
i'm not one of those
whether it's a limo or a cab driver that
type of distance
you know i come back in january listen
unless i get a [ __ ] sled dog
i'm not doing boston to [ __ ]
connecticut in [ __ ] january you know
it's just things that you look at
yourself and you go i don't really need
to do this
at this point in my life
i used to fly to buffalo in
january between you and i because of my
love for buffalo
it's a connecting flight
if that was that connecting flight to
somewhere else i wouldn't [ __ ] go you
know what i'm saying i really like
buffalo when i go to buffalo i feel like
home for two three days i feel like home
i like the wings i like the blue cheese
that's the way it is you know what i'm
saying i'll go to detroit in [ __ ]
january test me
i go to any part of michigan in [ __ ]
january i love all that type of [ __ ]
but that holiday travel rudy that [ __ ]
ain't for me puppy
that's when they lose luggage you got a
kilo in the suitcase
now you gotta go get ten smacks to the
face and you gotta tell the story i
don't know what happened
i left the stewardess was smiling you
know what i'm saying
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
i don't want to see nobody that bad for
the holidays
i went to new york last year i left on
the ninth i came back in the 13th with
my family
the plane deal we got
was insatiable
we could not believe the tickets we had
on virgin
because that's the time of the year to
really dig in
that's your last chance to fly cheap
nobody flies
between the 9th
and the 13th to 14th that's when the
christmas travel starts on the 15th
the plane tickets went down the hotel
tickets went down
i took them like put them in edgewater
we went over the city every day in the
ferry like movie stars and [ __ ]
we walked over went to see the tree and
we came back before the christmas rush
it's a very nice time and i want to work
when i was with my family next time i
work in new york or something i know
that's still pretty cool
but that's possibly the last week at
work after that
i don't like that christmas travel
brother what about you lee you don't fly
during yom kippur so you don't give a
[ __ ]
we don't fly during jewish holidays he
told me this years ago but you don't
want the people to know because he feels
embarrassed yeah yeah i feel very
embarrassed i've but i've never been
able
i've never been able to go home for
thanksgiving i've always wanted to but
like it's not really the biggest one
like that's why i i tended to go home
during december because thanksgiving
wasn't huge but it's too expensive like
a lot of people try to go back for both
and it would be like 600 bucks and i
couldn't do it
so uh i have like i've been here like
six years i think
i haven't been able to go back
but
then again
who wants to get stuck in that truck on
in that so it's not really snowing doug
oh yeah it's already slow did you see
that already yep two days i was talking
to justin
and he was asking me how about you going
here that week and i go dog you know
that's one of my dangers on weeks now
i'm going to dangerville those weeks and
he goes what are you talking about it
never snows there these times of the
year i got dawg i grew up there what the
[ __ ] do you think you're dealing with
all right mother nature sends you a zing
in november it's called dean
he said dog i had to leave new york it
was so [ __ ] cold
yeah we're california people dog yeah
that skin melts
it's
you know i had to turn the heat on this
morning i was embarrassed
47 degrees we got to turn heat on and
[ __ ] mom terry she comes in wow wow what
time the heat i'm freezing in here
[ __ ] go to new york at this age how
[ __ ] collapsed really so i've been
living like a doctor out there in the
sunlight rubbing number two on my legs
you know going to drink coffee i'm gonna
go shovel snow what do people die doing
shovel the [ __ ] snow that's what i
want to do
yeah i can't do it now i thought about
colorado a little the snow's a little
light i would consider like
a southern town i hear those southern
part of colorado's really booming
what about in new york city you wouldn't
have to shovel
listen
leave me alone
leave me alone where you gonna bother me
i just told you i don't want to live in
that cold weather whether i have to
shovel them you know
you know why there's a thousand angles
wildly
i can't see at this age getting out of
your [ __ ] house where your trunk let
this on and your robe
and have to turn your [ __ ] car on
full blast heat
sit there like a [ __ ] frozen [ __ ]
then clean off the windshield and go in
your house and get dressed and by the
time you come out your car is warmed up
i can't imagine doing this at this age
where these sizes are you tell me the
truth no i'm done
really yeah i'm good yeah i thought
there was something wrong with me i
thought about the advantages of moving
to new york listen
i love new york but in my heart that's
ship sale
i'm too old for new york
what advantage do i get from new york
right now i can do comedy at two in the
morning i don't want to be out after ten
i'm scared
it's a different world out there i love
playing new york
it's amazing oh i love going to gotham i
love [ __ ] dog yeah let me show you a
picture of pizza 50 yards away let me
tell you something this is the type of
pizza eat
if you i don't give a [ __ ] if you have
to go to the hospital from the gluten
you gotta eat this when you're in new
york just have the ambulance just cut it
in with christmas ellie go chris listen
the pizza down the corner i'm gonna eat
a slice part of my contract is we gotta
split the ambulance
i wanna get taken right to the hospital
to uh
this pizza
destroyed my insides i was like this is
i was just walking minding my own
business whistling down the street you
know me resizing
i don't bother nobody and i look over to
the side
and lo and behold
look at this
50 yards away has a lot of gluten yeah
but dairy don't matter you go to the
hospital
it's all right
and it's it's glowing
it's like you know what it looks like
those
the food that you know when you go to
japan
they'll have the menu in a in like a
shelf
outside of the restaurant like like
replicas plastic replicas of food and
they actually sometimes looks better
than the food that you get inside the
restaurant
uh that's what it reminds me of no i
took that picture that's no [ __ ]
replica
what else they got here they got the
slice they got the stromboli
they got everything in this place wow
they have two italians mexicans but it's
all right it all balances out like the
other night lee syed how you doing over
there you're seeing the devil aren't you
you never thought uncle joe is going to
take it deep into the murky waters
at two in the afternoon
one thing i've learned from you rudy is
you have to take care of yourself
i'm looking at you and i'm like this guy
is uh
is a savage
you're a savage
gotta take care of yourself you know
it's it's going on the road it's it's
hard oh my god it gets harder every yeah
three weekends you go
yeah and you and i you know we're not
like athletes
in the sense that you know let's say
you're derek jeter
you have a bad bad game
you know you strike out four times
during the game right next day
the stadium yankee center is going to be
filled again
no problem
right
you and i if we have one bad show people
ain't coming back
it's done you come back and you half
empty you know room
you know so every night you get you have
to be you have to hit a grand slam every
single night
you get and you have to be in shape for
that you can be sick
you can't be feeling ill or tired
i got it's it's it's so funny how you
learn for me one of the biggest lessons
was and people get upset with me is i
don't smoke pot with people on the road
that's the biggest [ __ ] road to
[ __ ] pneumonia
especially when you travel a lot
i don't mingle too much
people want to hug you they're coughing
that's okay but i won't smoke pot which
it's amazing how many people come up to
your coffin and they want to smoke pot
where you're like dog i gotta go do a
movie next week and do this and they're
like no no i had a pneumonia but it
wasn't it went away i went to the doctor
you're like doug it don't matter
i get a lot of sleep on the road man
i don't do a lot of movement on the road
rudy sarzo
i'm gonna be strictly honest here i
[ __ ] around
in my career for 16 years
i go on the road for
no money
and i'd act like an [ __ ] on stage
i'd have a set list but i wouldn't
i didn't really care what they thought
i was a comedy store comic and i was
happy with that
i would open up for joe rogan
and i would do well in those shows
because joe would pay me well so i had
to do well i'd be a little prepared
but i didn't really get it until i
started headlining
and i started people realizing people
paying 20 hours to come in to see me
how important it is for me
to be in a certain shape
a certain state of mind
i got a bat 60 percent because even if i
bat 60 i could turn that into 80. do you
follow me we have tricks
i have tricks to confuse you
comically
where even if the closer doesn't work
his first 30 minutes are really
hilarious
you know there's rooms i go to now that
i'm not connecting with them the first
35 minutes really
and all of a sudden i twisted on them
and i turned my energy on them and i
focus on the last 15 and three quarters
of the room gives me a standing ovation
even though i ate [ __ ] for 35 minutes
i have tricks i've been doing it for 25
[ __ ] years you know what i'm saying
i'm a hooker you know what i could do to
your dick
i could lick it slide it on fire suck
the blowhard out of your ass show you
your kidney yeah you know i could do a
doctor's test better than he can i'll
let you know what you got before the
doctor you got a certain taste in your
sperm you're missing some [ __ ] carrot
juice
wake up [ __ ] look at the shape of
you lee well you need another star
league that's what the problem is i
might yeah yeah yeah look at the shape
here but uh
we and you know what i'm talking about
rudy sager you see with me with singers
a singer a singer will come out and say
guys by the way i don't know what the
[ __ ] you're thinking those motley crew
days are over we're lowering it from 16
to 3. you know what i'm saying i got a
sound whatever and you go see them and
you know this thing is struggling this
is 20 [ __ ] years ago yeah but even
when the singer's struggling you know
the more struggling the singer goes
through the bigger the explosions and
the light show on stages it's deflecting
there you go i do the same we as
comedians yeah we do the exact same
thing
if if uh
thomas ward used to have a great joke
that he had a little dick
so whatever he [ __ ] he made [ __ ]
happen in the room like he'd break a
window and he'd break a lamp
and he hit him with his shoe and [ __ ]
you know i don't know what the joke was
but basically that he would
he would detract them from having sex
you know
uh
as a comedian
this night i go up there and i can't
believe what's happening rudy you know
what i'm talking about
this night's when you're on stage even
if i say hello
they puke them with laughter
and there's nights they don't laugh for
the first 10 minutes i got to twist it
on them and take them down a different
dungeon
i got to show them a different [ __ ]
coffin you know what i'm saying you got
to take them somewhere else and even
though that wasn't the that wasn't the
[ __ ] schedule
that wasn't the plan how long does it
take you to realize that
ten minutes
i just did three shows i'm not i'm i'm
just saying uh
uh i'm i'm talking about the situation
here i just did three shows
these people on the way out that were
calling ambulances they couldn't breathe
okay i taped the show with lee
i listened to it now when i listen to it
i know what to say and how to say it
i just learned that now after 25 years
because he started taping my sets before
i started taping the special
i did the exact same set the second
night
the exact same first eight nine ten
twelve minutes
and it didn't go nowhere
and i said a specific line that wasn't a
curse
and it really didn't go nowhere and then
i flipped it
and i told the story to bring them down
to level
let me bring you down to my level let me
tell you what i go through
you know when i was 28 i did this this
this this and this you take them to a
specific situation
now i get them laughing from a different
corner of their heart
you're following me now i'm getting them
so we have cur kurt but guess what
well i'm telling that story and i'm
trying to tell that story to form i'm
really trying to [ __ ] think about
what's going to come out of my mouth
next
so i can keep these [ __ ] alive
now i'm resuscitating them little by
little that woman that was staring at me
like i kicked a kid in the mouth she's
laughing now she's actually giggling at
my jokes even though i throw a [ __ ]
joke at it and now
you
think about the next move and if you
could think of your next three steps
that quickly
you got them
we'll worry about the next three steps
when we get to them let me worry about
the next three steps
now i know exactly where the [ __ ] i'm
going
you know i started hanging around
comedians and when when i met uh uh sam
kennison we had the same management
you know as when i was in white snake
here we have you know we share we share
a lot you know as far as the business
goes and i got to play on this record
because of that because we had you know
the manager called me and say hey you
know yeah can you be tomorrow at the the
studio and do this song wild thing with
sam and then from then on and you know
we we became really close friends
hung out with the family you know malika
his wife and and sabrina and you know so
we have a really really strong
relationship but
along with sam came
all the other comedians
you know uh he had the uh the com the
outlaws of comedy you
yeah all of that and jimmy what's his
name jimmy um
not schubert
jimmy schubert jimmy schubert yeah
and so you know that was kind of like my
my introduction to to comedy world you
know and i gotta tell you you know i i
saw a lot of shows uh with sam he used
to go and try his material in palm
springs and i used to have a house out
there and sam would love to
rent out elvis's home
in palm springs so he would stay there
and then go down to the local comedy
club and just do do shows you know then
i would bring them over over to my house
and
mess them up with like
these drinks that i used to make
scorpions and then he would do the next
show or just blotter completely gone you
know meanwhile sabrina was recording
everything you know
and
i i really
gained so much respect for you guys
because you guys you you can't really
deflect here's just you with the
microphone and the audience you got
nothing you don't have a drum solo with
some [ __ ] going wrong
okay drum solo or guitar solo or a wawa
you don't even have a wawa
you know it's like it's you with your
dick in your hand up there
in front of the stage one light on you
most of the time and the audience and
that's it
and it's not like you know like you have
a bit you know like we
we know how to pace our set list because
we're going to put like a song that the
crowd is familiar with and then we throw
another hit like three songs into the
set then we finish the do a
finish with a strong song and then the
encore is the song everybody's waiting
for you know so you know we we kind of
like we're holding the the the audience
you know like like
you know at ransom here because they
they want to hear certain songs
with you guys you come up with new stuff
all the time
i'm not laughing
[ __ ] just fell over you know he passed
out anyway
oh he's been
so you know like i was saying i'm really
really impressed with how you guys are
able to every single night be able to
handle that
it's amazing i mean i i saw sam get up
on stage
doing like two shows and one night like
he did a whole weekend at caesar's
palace in the big ballroom
and
the second night he hadn't slept from
the night before
you know he stayed up partying
and he would just hit the stage
now we were hanging out at in his suite
and we knew how messed up he was but as
soon as he hit that stage he was spot on
and he had the crowd
right there the crowd was cheering for
him even before he opened his mouth
you know like like what you're saying
you know you you could just grunt until
the microphone and people will be
[ __ ] laughing if i
tonight i got the caesar's palace if i
went up the first night
i know there's a package waiting for me
afterward
that's the best show you're ever gonna
see if i know there's a suite i know
that 99
somebody's gonna lick my nuts and put a
fire crack in my [ __ ] i know i'm
gonna party with rudy and god knows who
else
those two shows are gonna be the best
show you've ever seen in your life but i
gotta be in bed by five
and i gotta get up and i gotta sweat a
little bit
and i gotta write
and the first show that night is gonna
be a little rusty
the second show is gonna be great
if i stay up all night and go to the
show
you better give them their money back
you better give them that money back
like i would never even plan a binge
if i had a big show the next night an
open mic a 50 show yeah [ __ ] that i
couldn't even because
my heart wouldn't be connected with my
head
there were so many times in miami i was
committed to the weekend and it was so
horrible rudy because
i went from a comic with emotion
to a
press here
and i could see the audience knew it
they they laughed
but it wasn't what the joke was because
there was no emotion in the joke i
became when we went to the wilbur
i got a big-time anxiety attack when i
first walked off the stakes there was a
lot of people there and if you asked lee
the first two minutes at the wilbur i
was very rigid
i didn't try to move around too much so
i didn't have to breathe that much so i
wouldn't pass out on stage in front of
[ __ ] a thousand people
so the first two or three minutes even
if you listen to it uh
you'll feel my tone and everything
awesome once i became animated
was when the room changed
once the arms start moving the whole
[ __ ] deal and
that's it
that's when i start pulling them in but
if i just stand there in front of the
microphone like i'm going to recite the
[ __ ] uh
proclamation mockimation whatever the
[ __ ] that is a population bucket late
whatever that abe lincoln it's not gonna
work out for me
i gotta move i gotta get involved
you know a little [ __ ] like that i
started doing this joke and one day lee
pulled me over
and he goes hey man uh i like when you
do this little thing
and that little thing gets a tremendous
laugh
i did it one night on stage because i
was high
and i had eight people in the audience
and i was lit being myself and
you know uh
just uh
you learned so much in 25 years rudy
sago i don't have to tell you i know
yeah i don't have to tell you i love the
guy that walks up to you now and goes
hey man
you my the way back then dude you know
i've been playing for six years i played
just like you or whatever and
the first 10 minutes of the conversation
is very interesting
but the next 10 minutes he's kind of not
putting you down but he's
talking in a way like uh
he's trying to do something to you now
if you were back with randy god bless
his soul and ozzy you might have punched
him in the [ __ ] mouth rudy sarso you
know the type i'm talking about
but because you are who you are today
you look at him
you say a prayer for him yeah and as you
walk away you predict this future you go
i'll give this [ __ ] bum three years
you don't tell nobody because you're a
decent person and you call it right
every time
from the way they came up to you and
approached you do you follow me you ever
had that
you know what i'm talking about i get it
i get it yeah it's it's it's uh yeah
but i love when a comic comes up to me
and tries to
um
speak a certain way to me
you know
and 20 years ago i would have kicked him
in the stomach but knowing who i am
today i look at him
and i could tell by his attitude
where he's going to end up just because
he's moving too fast
i know before this even gets going this
is going to fall apart and he's going to
take him a few years to get back on this
because of this attitude that he's
showing towards me you know what i'm
saying yeah like i've been doing this
for [ __ ] 25 years you've been doing
it for four and somebody liked you at a
festival that's two different [ __ ]
worlds i've been banging out at the
store for [ __ ]
15 [ __ ] years following paul mooney
and joe rogan and tonight i got to
follow ari sofia we think that's like
these guys are explosive in 15 [ __ ]
minutes you go down there and follow
[ __ ] dalia see what happens to you
you go down there with a base
with a [ __ ] chick that lights herself
on fire and they'll just look at you
rudy though that's how strong delete you
know
you learn how to navigate yourself after
all those acts
you could do two things you could take
that energy
that they left on stage
do something good with it talk well
about the comment that just came up
and flow with his energy and now you
stole the show or
you could fight that energy and try to
be a [ __ ] wise ass
and try to say something sarcastic about
that act
and the audience shuts down on you like
a [ __ ]
like uh
i don't even know what to compare it to
i'm so [ __ ] high right now
[Music]
it happens in music too because we got
you know at one point at some point
you're the opening band or at some point
you are the headliner
so it's exactly the same thing you know
the opening band sometimes you can write
on the energy of the opening band you
know
because the opening band actually gets
to warm up you know the audience
and then you actually matter of fact if
you if if the opening ban has a certain
energy you might shift your your your
opening song
to maybe a higher energy so you can
actually match
the way that they ended because the last
thing you want to do is to drop down the
energy if they really end up with a
high-energy song the lesson you come in
with like a mid-tempo even though it
might be a well-known song
but all of a sudden you're like
bringing all that
that energy down and you don't want to
do that i've been to concerts so [ __ ]
fired up already
and the band has come out
the opening band has been [ __ ]
fantastic
the headline has come out he opened up
tremendous there's lights
the guitars are great the drums are on
fire it sounds like the album
they got you the second song is
fantastic the third song is fantastic
and then somebody's ego gets in the way
and they do two or three ballads in a
row no two ballads and this is a song
off our new album well
you just [ __ ] stab me in the neck you
[ __ ]
okay i don't want to hear a song from
the new album and i don't want to hear
this [ __ ] ego fest that you did you
had me you had me
you [ __ ] had me
i'll tell you what band killed me and
what like that
nazareth
i went to see nazareth june
6th of 19 oh god
maybe 81
at the palladium
they did a version of cocaine
acoustic
oh yeah it's like when me and him yeah
but after that i don't know what
happened
they did like they opened up with hair
of the dog now you're messing with the
son of a [ __ ] that just blows the room
up you open up with that song the room
just goes [ __ ] ape [ __ ]
then they did another big energy one
forget about it then they did that when
they swear let's switch up the gears a
little bit that's one of our favorites
from mary clapton and they had [ __ ]
like six guitars everybody had a guitar
and dog i gotta tell you right off the
bat it was brilliant
brilliant i wasn't even that much entire
clapping i knew the song cocaine it was
brilliant and then they started singing
a song about a girl they met in
cleveland
and after that you just want to pull the
plug
you can't do this to me
you can't do this to about the girl in
cleveland that way we're having a good
time here my friend just bought a
grandma blow and you want to [ __ ]
throw this nightmare into the show
i've been in a few bands that during our
our opening band stage you know in our
career
i would i would say it was it was pretty
frightening to have to follow
with aussie we were opening up for saxon
in
in europe and it was a 45-minute set and
i got to tell you it was the most
intense 45 minutes of your life
and for anybody to have to follow that i
don't care who you are it was it was
just like how are you gonna do this
right the next one was actually well
with quite a riot it it was pretty good
uh
even though the headliners that we work
with they were you know especially zz
top z top was the hardest band ever to
open up for
because it has the most dedicated
audience they're fanatic you know they
all the one they're they're fuzzy top
they don't care who you are you know
like we're talking about you don't care
about who the opening band is you know
during a certain time
then white snake we were an opening band
and i gotta tell you by the time you
finish with still of the night
i think it's pretty much over
you know i don't care who's gonna follow
the band you know it was that strong it
was that still i was yeah that's strong
okay in a 45 minute
i was going to a lot of concerts back
then i'm trying to write a book now and
i don't even know
there's parts of me that wants to break
it down but there's parts to me that are
the highlight of my concert career
what the [ __ ] was i gonna ask you god
dammit
oh you was talking about 45 minutes of
ozzie in those days in a 45 minute set
yeah i mean you guys turned the shades
down and you opened up mr crowley
right uh we opened up with i don't know
actually it was the uh the diary of the
madman tour
version because the record had just come
out in europe okay so we were probably
opening up with uh
with over the mountain which is really
intense anyways
this is the second tour the one i saw in
new york city uh the one after the
palladium okay so the one i saw after
new year the one i saw at the palladium
yeah you either opened up with i don't
know we open up without her no i don't
but that was the following tour
okay so that was the when i saw you at
the palladium what did you open up with
i don't know yeah because i remember it
was there was no over them he did
something for he he [ __ ] stopped too
yeah no but the palladium yeah it was
you guys headline yeah we did believer
right and we did uh flying high again
flying high again
from the record that was not released
yet yeah
but that was longer than 45 minutes oh
yeah no because we were headlining but
i'm talking about 45 minutes 45 minutes
tell me the 45 minute set in the
beginning i am we're i you know i could
just see
again i can just see the first three and
the side a yeah sunday is a [ __ ]
monster inside b is a monster yeah the
uh the ballad would have been just uh uh
revelation mother earth mother earth
which is tremendous goes into stealing
tremendous tremendous yeah tremendous
tremendous
it was just insane 45 minutes so what
they did is they they shortened tommy
eldridge's drum solo tremendous you know
that was too much and it was packed
packed with like high-intensity playing
and music yeah it was insane yeah yeah
and it was great because we we would get
off the stage by nine o'clock the latest
at 8 30 maybe
get into rental rental cars and with
tommy
randy and me
hit the autobahn
and we'll be in the next town before the
club open
in in the in the hotel so we were just
partying right after right after the
show in the next city you know germany
we're just getting on the autobahn tommy
is an incredible driver so we hit about
160 miles an hour and we were like in
less than two hours in the next town
yeah
insane party our asses off
i still remember the back of the
palladium that night
i got there with my buddies and i knew a
spot there was a place that you walked
and there was a fence but there was a
cut in the fence
and you knew that if you walked back
there you walked behind one of the
buildings and that's where the cool
people that were going to the concert
would party
that's where they'd be like six or seven
broads and the people were doing little
bumps and [ __ ] and i still remember
going back then and walking in and
jesus that was so long ago i was a
[ __ ] kid really sorry so
i was a [ __ ]
kid i'm [ __ ] a lost
kid a [ __ ] lost kid
with four other [ __ ] lost
[ __ ] what's pino there huh
pinot no by that time pinot crowley was
there moved to miami crowley was there
yeah i went with this kid didi quintero
now i don't know if it was that concert
or the second one at the meadowlands
where we leave the show and his shirt is
ripped
and we go dede what happened he goes let
me tell you what happened i'm sitting
there minding my own business and some
guy come behind me and started dry
humping me so i go what did you do
because i just beat the [ __ ] out of them
right there in the show and they threw
me out i've been waiting for you guys to
get us for a ride home i don't know if
it's the palladium
or the other one
oh my god but i had seen like
so this is when you came to the
palladium was 81 82
81 okay so 81 so at that time
i had seen
three or four shows in the palladium
listen
i don't go to a lot of shows rudy you
know i almost went to sabbath we had to
go to new york that night
but i'll tell you how lucky that was man
i was lucky enough to see i asked you
when you walked in here what that place
seated
and you told me about 12 to 1500 maybe
1600 they were standing
i was in there
for four shows
that are still etched in my mind that
it's the reason why
i saw such great shows there
that i know in my heart nothing will
beat it really
i saw iron maiden there in the first
album with paul diana
they went in and opened up for judas
priest i think
then i went back then saw
that leopard open up a judas priest
another time
then i went in there and saw you [ __ ]
savages in there
then
i went in there and saw ac dc with brian
johnson
on the second night of their [ __ ]
tour at the palladium in new york city
it was august 2nd and it was a thousand
[ __ ] degrees do you understand me
when i went home that night even after
the bus ride
my jeans were [ __ ] drenched really so
and i and i went to see james brown
there also
and they were all not about the show the
shows were always money judas priest in
a small place you guys with randy rhodes
in a [ __ ] theater i want america to
think about what i'm talking about here
think about when you go to a movie
theater now
when you go to a [ __ ] big movie
dinner now that was the palladium i
don't remember if they had a balcony i
think they did this video on youtube
from that show i don't remember if they
had a balcony
but the sound was sensational in there
rudy i got to [ __ ] sit there with my
jaw dropped
i saw my buddy from the [ __ ] projects
in 64th street
take his hat off
throw it up on stage at angus young
and young bent over picked it up put it
on and then threw it back in the
audience me and my homies from jersey
almost [ __ ] died do you understand me
i mean i don't need that i saw [ __ ] in
there that
was just too good
people freak out now when i talk to
people and i go i went to see aussie at
the planet no [ __ ] it wasn't the show it
was the experience
me and these two guys probably went and
copped the grandma blow
and we used to get that in those days
you got the bottle with the spoon at the
end we used to go to union city the east
west and they sold uh
drug paraphernalia they're still there
rudy sarzo
back in the day we had the the
mcdonald's coffee little spoons
oh my god you never use one of those
i never went to mcdonald's
but we went there just for the spoon
when you're doing blow who goes to
mcdonald's you know what i'm saying
rudy always a pleasure to see you man
you
i'm gonna read some ads and i'll get you
out of there give me some ads lee what
the [ __ ] my brother lee is jacked up
tonight
to the gills yes sir yes he is don't
make you believe yes
yeah i agree oh my god uncle joey put
the my look on you that thanksgiving my
luke i guarantee lee will start cooking
that turkey tonight by the time these
wives get home
leo have the turkey marinated in the
[ __ ] oven like a good soldier with a
little [ __ ]
with a little suit on he'll be ready to
go with attention but listen bro you
wake up this turkey
you slow cook that [ __ ] get up
every hour on the hour throw a piece of
butter on it and rub it in there with
your little fingers with a glove on
who's better than you you know how juicy
that turkey would be
you do that [ __ ] thing you learned
from all those chef shows you stick the
[ __ ] needle in it
i know you got a show on dvr or you go
to yelp
and they teach you how to get the thing
you stab the [ __ ] turkey with the
stick and it tells you if it's cooked
inside don't look at me like a like you
don't know what i'm talking about four
years of college this year i gotta live
with you know
i'm telling you he's gonna get him with
his girlfriend's sick they're gonna [ __ ]
that turkey you know i was making an
apology okay yeah you listen listen to
me how many turkeys paula make in their
life yeah as many as me okay so you
trust somebody why don't you you might
as well trust me making your [ __ ]
turkey i would not trust you
for many reasons you might as well
get a gun and [ __ ] shoot yourself
because somebody's going to get sick
listen on the way home till i stop and
rouse and get the little thing that you
stab the turkey with and see what the
temperature of the turkey we're telling
rudy sarzo please
he thinks i'm [ __ ] around temperature
of the turkey uh
oh no i don't know what it is oh jesus
christ what he says i thought you were
like a half a chef
i thought somewhere in your lustrous
career
you had a job somewhere in the back i
did well making veggie burgers no we
don't talk about that [ __ ] on the show
we don't talk about that [ __ ] on the
show fight club don't talk about fight
club we don't talk about veggie burgers
in the church
listen
you know me dog i don't [ __ ] around with
you people i was telling somebody that i
was talking to shane and my main man
matt lotman we were getting called for
the other day and they had asked me
about underwear me undies i said listen
me undies is fantastic why cut this [ __ ]
it's the holidays i'm gonna tell you why
me undies was fantastic a year and a
half ago i got certain uh
not this time was it this timely yeah
no
yeah this time i got surgery and i
couldn't take a shower for a day and i
took a shower before i went to the
hospital and the next day i went to take
a shower and as a man we always take a
scratch and we sniff and it was clean it
was not even sweaty
because
meundies me undies fabric is made by
modor m-o-d-a-l
and it pulls away the [ __ ] moisture
from your skin and i'm telling you this
off the [ __ ] cuff you understand me
picture a world where putting a new pair
underwear isn't just fresh you're
stepping into a better day think about
it
underwear is the first thing you put on
and the last thing you take off why
would you set off anything less than the
best
feeling underwear on the planet me on
these focus solely on producing the most
comfortable underwear you'll ever
experience
my friends at meundies sent me a few
pairs a while back and now i can't
imagine wearing anything else it really
makes me each day that much better for
the price of two cocktails me undies
will deliver your new favorite pair
underwear right to your doorstep
better day guaranteed try them on if
they're not comfortable
and they're the best feeling undies
you've ever had they'll refund you and
let you keep the first order for free
all right including the price is the
sweet touch of moldova what i was
talking about
a special fabric made with the best in
class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton is what i'm talking
about these uber cozy undies are sold
exclusively at the meondys website where
you enjoy free shipping
to the us and canada who's better than
you
and for a limited time everyone in the
audience gets 20 off their first order
but you have to go to a special url
meundies.com
joe you get
meundies.com joey with the me undies
better day guarantee you have nothing to
lose so don't wait any longer go to
meundies.com joey right now for 20 off
your first order that's
meundies.com no the undies dot com slash
joey okay listen the holiday season is
coming
lee
this days i don't talk to lee no more
ever since the girlfriend moved in i
don't talk too late maybe we talk every
day and i understand don't make don't
don't don't justifiably
and i found that today he came to my
house i went to smoke pot in the
backyard and as well walk into the
backyard he saw my toilet
and he saw the portable [ __ ] uh bidet
and he stopped and he got kind of pale
like also he had to take a [ __ ] and i
lured him outside and he came over and
he ate but i could see he had to go home
he was acting [ __ ] funny
and he left you know why he's been
acting creepy lately ever since he got
the bidet he doesn't answer the phone no
more and i don't blame him rudy sarzo
you ever heard of the day
i grew up with bidet in in cuba cuba
that's big and cute my mom had one in
north bergen absolutely tell them you
must have it be dave it's a [ __ ]
tremendous thing i agree with that you
got it we got to get it not only for men
but for women too no no no no
no no and you get the scrotum you got
everything there's no bacteria listen
but days are making a comeback thank you
to hellotushy.com that's why i love
these people
but days are bad you don't know what a
bidet is because you've been living in a
[ __ ] cave for 20 years but days they
spray your butt clean with water i grew
up with a bidet in north bergen in my
house i'm giving that terrace they are
stupendous tremendous healthy they keep
you nice down there and thanks to tushy
with the sleek bidet that clips onto
your existing toilet and it sprays your
butt completely solid with fresh water
to get your mufflers clean so you're not
sitting on bacteria you're causing
hemorrhoids yeast infection and most
importantly you're sitting there causing
rotten ass you ever sit there on the
computer
three four hours and you're thinking
what's going on with the world before
you think about that stuff think about
your muffling what's going on down there
how you ate a cheeseburger for lunch
what could be developing down there if
you got hello tushy this [ __ ] don't
happen all right and it's
environmentally one of the best things
going on because you don't need no more
paper all right so that means more trees
and it uses one pint of fresh water
number two tushy just came out with
towels on the website too they're
[ __ ] tremendous
so tushy stan stands behind that product
60 day
guarantee all right and here's the best
they got a white or gold tushy
but here's the beauty of this stuff
right now is the season this stuff is
fantastic it's not going to cost your
arm real leg go to hellotushy.com right
now i'm telling you right now this is
the stocking stuffer you dream about you
all know some [ __ ] chubby dude you
look at somebody you go you know what i
can tell
i'm no fortune teller but that guy's
[ __ ] stinks you ever look at somebody
that's sitting there you're like i know
either his feet or his ass stick i do
this kind of judging when i'm bored
why take the chance make this [ __ ]
day go to hellotushy.com right now
slash church
and get 10 percent off your order all
right again
hellotushy.com slash church and get 10
percent off your order
and that's it and that's that dog the
special comes out december 8 go to cso
tv
code
joey j-o-e-y get two months for free
listen to me this is my thanksgiving i
need you people to do this for me i
don't ask you for a dick i try to get
your muffler clean and i try for you to
stay sexy when you're wearing underwears
who's better than me and don't forget on
it for the holidays another stocking
stocking stuffer you go to honey.com
right now get some alpha brain you're
all [ __ ] up you're robots you want to
leave your wife for an 18 year old that
plays the [ __ ] piano who gives a [ __ ]
get your head together you need some on
it [ __ ] and they got a money-back
guarantee boom what's the code church
c-h-u-r-c-h 10 percent off delivered to
your house one more time for my people
on it you know me i love tushy with all
my heart go to tushy.com hellotushy.com
and look at the great stuff ciso tv i
need you to do this uncle joey and honey
[ __ ] is my brother mr rudy sarzo
my pride and joy when i was a kid i was
in a dark corner and he took me out of
it just by being [ __ ] cuban and don't
forget tomorrow night irvine boom 11 23
8 o'clock show and i'll see you
[ __ ] in portland oregon
december 1st start the month off on a
good week december 1st to the third and
i come back and i celebrate santa baba
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with december 4th
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with some novices here i'm making up
stories here
have a great thanksgiving me and lee
want to tell you we love you all our
heart thank you for supporting the
church
without you guys we have dick man thank
you for making our world complete man
thank you for listening and for being
loyal you know who the [ __ ] you are you
don't need for people to tell your
[ __ ] name and [ __ ] all right i'll see
you guys next week stay black
ciao
what do you think about that lisa we're
gonna put music on lee what's your
picture
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you